let's go Brandon has reached number one
number two number three and number eight
on iTunes displacing Adele pissing off a
lot of Lefty establishment media critics
but something else strange has happened
now I'm not entirely sure they've done
this across the board but when you go to
Apple's website to look at the top ten
let's go Brandon
not there none of them there's two
different ver well there's three
different versions there's two different
songs one of the songs has three
different versions like a remix an
extended version and it's dominating the
top of the charts
well it kind of looks like iTunes has
completely removed the songs all of them
from the top charts because the only way
to maintain these
I don't know left left wing ideas and
culture is to censor the right
there's like a meme where they say
I think it's from 4chan that any
sufficiently open Forum will become
right wing and that's why leftists
comment with heavy-handed rules because
otherwise it would just be right wing
well iTunes started to get dominated and
so they have to gain Take Back Control
of the cultural uh institutions we've
got a couple more stories though Biden
is getting absolutely obliterated by
Mansion he's losing everything the IRS
tax reporting thing where they're going
to track your account gone beautiful
Medical Care like all this stuff just
being gutted the bill's now cut in half
Biden is losing yes because they're
desperate to pass something before next
year because they know they're going to
lose the house and then we got some
other cultural stories apparently some
very strange commercials um what is this
Doritos put on a commercial yeah where
um a Latino family summons their dead
uncle
and then discover that he's gay it's
just like a weird commercial meanwhile I
didn't know ghosts could eat Doritos I
didn't either is that like something
they thought they couldn't maybe they
have ghost Doritos ghost chips ghost
chips instead of ghost chips and then
there's oh my God yes I love it there's
another story where apparently Twix made
a commercial that has nothing to do with
Twix of course it's just like creepy a
kid wearing a dress just satanism
basically yeah if you watch the
commercial so um my friends Luke and Ian
are currently on a date together they
won't be on the show tonight no they're
they're both out
um and we're being joined by Libby
Emmons you want to introduce yourself I
think people know you yeah here I am how
you doing I'm Libby Emmons I'm the
editor-in-chief of the post millennial
and there's some other guys sitting here
this other guy
who am I Sheamus Cog going to Freedom
Tunes it's great to be back and I am
really enjoying our our different crew
for this evening and I was telling Libby
this evening that she's like a magnet
for chaos and then we almost hit a deer
on the way down and I was like wow it's
not joking it's very true I didn't know
I was a magnet for chaos we survived
we're here I'm glad we're here it's
gonna be a great show Luke and Ian need
to watch out this might become the new
cast yeah I know right yeah
yeah gym guest oh that's right that's
right no it's not true no it's showcase
all right let's chat tell us all right
all right you do the ad read all right
well that's not ladies and gentlemen
look at this go to what what do we got
here what's supposed to be stronger
bones in life perfect go to
strongerbones in life.com and you can
get your ageless multi-collogion from
BioTrust this stuff's awesome actually
it adds like a nice creamy texture to
your drinks it's got five different
types of collagen and if you are
becoming an old man which I am of course
I'm 35 so the aging process has begun I
love the stuff I put it in my in my
coffee and I also love the other keto
stuff too but this stuff's pretty good
so if you want healthier skin nails if
you want to look young and supple then
you're going to want to go to stronger
bones in life and pick up some of your
your ageless multi-collagen 51 off
BioTrust says you get a 60 day money
back guarantee the healthy aging support
of collagen in its ideal forms five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources
for every order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org today BioTrust has
provided over 5 million meals to Hungry
kids please help them hit their goal of
6 million Meals by this year it is
non-GMO and free of artificial colors
flavors preservatives and sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and
RBST no odor or taste unlike bone broth
there's no clumping free shipping with
every order free VIP live health and
fitness coaching from BioTrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and the free new
e-report 14 foods for amazing skin with
every order guys myotrust very obviously
because they we do we do several reads
for them per month
their company willing to help support us
in the work we do and that's huge
considering the left is always trying to
go after advertisers and get that that
Revenue pulled from from various shows
so show them your support if this is
something you're looking for
you want some collagen check out
strongerbones in life.com and don't
forget to go to timcast.com become a
member but boy do I have an announcement
look at this if you go to timcast.com
and then you click store if you scroll
then to the bottom you'll be graded by a
new shirt a lot of people are like Tim
why don't you have any new shirts and
you're like that's a good point we need
a new shirt so we cranked one out this
is step on snack and find out it is a a
joke from the Vlog cast Castle Vlog
where can't who does the animations just
make silly shirts for Luke to wear and
so one of them was step on snack and
find out and there's a little cute angry
snake who's you know telling you to
watch out so if you want the step-on
snuck and find out I'm we're ordering a
whole bunch because this is like this
looks amazing and we've got like what is
it what color is that demo green camo
green olive green the green yeah yeah it
looks pretty good I like it so we're
gonna get a whole bunch of these yes and
then you know we'll have them here but
uh I'm really excited for this one and
we're gonna be making a whole bunch more
so don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel again you go
to timcast.com become a member click
store get your stuff up on snack and
find out shirt because it's funny and
I'm gonna get a bunch but let's talk
about the news here we go this is where
it gets really weird from popvortex.com
you can see iTunes top 10 music charts
USA
top songs
let's go Brandon featuring Tyson James
and Chandler Crump Bryson Gray
let's go Brandon extended version Loza
Alexander Three let's go Brandon Loza
Alexander knocking Adele out of the
first place position then you get a
walker Hayes you get Ed Sheeran then you
get Elton John and the number eight is
let's go Brandon wow wow but here's
where he was crazy check this out check
this out so someone chatted actually
when we were starting the show that they
removed it and I'm like no no that would
be too obvious so I pulled up
music.apple.com us top 100 USA
and it's not there but this this is a
different chart so I don't I don't know
exactly what's going on because this is
not the same chart this is the most
played songs in the us updated every day
and this is from apple.com
but they're different songs so I don't
know like Adele is there easy on me but
then they have Drake yeah and Drake
isn't up here so maybe I don't know what
I don't know am I missing something here
that's why I didn't title it that's why
I didn't that's why we need Casey Kasem
yeah exactly tell us what's going on you
guys remember Casey cases I do no who's
that what am I myself Casey Kasem he did
like the top four yeah oh my God it was
great and he would he had this great
voice and I think he lived to be about
175 years old pretty much yeah yeah I
didn't do it like announced that you
know it's like a lich like an Undead
yeah yeah yeah kind of like the Dorito
commercial yeah if you if you heard the
voice you might know it I bet you'd do a
good impression of it too probably I
guess here's what's funny about this
right so where's the store here we go
this is from showbiz411 Adele booming at
radio but temporarily knocked off iTunes
top spot by moronic anti-biting song
nice headline okay this hold on hold on
it's from October 25th right okay here's
what he says
easy on me was knocked off its perch at
number one on iTunes after 10 straight
days the temporary displacer is a
moronic single called let's go Brandon
by Bryson gray Tyson an anti-biden
record for anti-vaxxers idiots idiots
are pushing this piece of crap up the
iTunes chart but no one in their right
mind would spend money on it it's not a
song or record it's just garbage Adele
will be back at number one tomorrow
maybe that's why it's not on the maybe
that's why maybe people aren't buying it
they're just listening to it oh I don't
know maybe but but it is in the top list
I mean you saw it on your phone you
checked yeah let's go Brendan's there
and then but this guy said October 25th
it would be knocked off the chart out
Adele will be number one sorry dude also
I love that like this the answer on it
it's like the Auntie Biden song is
moronic and what like Adele makes music
for intellectuals
I don't have anything against her but is
that just like more sophisticated it's
all pop music right pretty much hello
yeah yeah it's me
it's a great song Let's go Brandon is
you know the one hit wonder of of uh
2021 yeah but it's two different songs
it's there there's two versions of it
well there's more than two versions
there's two different songs and then
multiple versions of one song remixes
and stuff yeah so I people like let's go
Brandon yeah they they really really
like it and one thing that I enjoy and
look we all do this we're all guilty of
it but people who don't produce anything
trashing on something that everybody
else loves right it's like this this
song got into the top charts three times
literally three times the exact same
song this guy it's moronic it's terrible
no no no no now help me with this guys
um when remember the song F Donald Trump
yeah no F Donald Trump
yeah it came out in 2016. it actually
reached number one on iTunes November
7th 2020. oh nice yeah so F it's called
FDT is the name of the song but can I
say something oh sorry well isn't isn't
let's go Brandon a more creative way of
saying it than just like this guy yeah
like you're saying after this guy that's
moronic that that's why I think let's go
Brandon does does really well but what I
was gonna say is we're conservatives
outraged over F Donald Trump I I think I
think I remember some people being like
how crucial like it knocked Adele off
how could this have happened it was
crude but that's because conservatives
are always saying that pop music is
crazy that's true yeah yeah like WAP
remember when yeah they're right gosh
that was hysterical and also that song
okay that's kind of a mess it's a very
nasty
it's not a sexy song
there's no like there's no uh entry when
when Ben Shapiro read the lyrics to WAP
oh my God and then and then someone took
it and put it overwhelmed of course that
was legit hilarious true comedy so I I
kind of feel like that's the big
difference between like if you're in the
culture you're not in the cult you know
I like Adele I think Adele's really good
yeah and um Ed Sheeran I don't know a
whole lot about him but I got it I got
this really boring I like Elton John
Elton John's got a lot of great Classics
no me too yeah yeah Goodbye Yellow Brick
Road excellent music rocket man come on
yeah I prefer William Shatner's cover
but also good but so so look I forgot
about that one it's so good Rocket Man
no but this is what's funny like even if
conservatives were criticizing the F
Donald Trump song they weren't going
they knocked it down exactly exactly you
know what's interesting about that too
is like so the uh the thing where low
Art became High art American culture is
what allowed Adele to be something like
critically acclaimed and now they don't
like that there's more low art already
low art out also part of the thing with
let's go Brandon is if the song was you
know FDT but yeah fjb right dead
um that would get censored all over the
place oh yeah it would be like hate
speech it would be racist to call the
old white male President right the names
or something like somehow that would all
be wrong so this is a nice little
workaround of censorship as well which
we obviously need a great deal of these
I think I think Bryson's version is
family friendly I haven't heard it like
he doesn't cuss or anything good for him
because he was saying that YouTube
deletes like the Kidz Bop version like
they're all popping of this in the car
with their family yep they say fudge
yeah you know and ship I just released
Biden Bops if anyone wants to check that
was so great
gosh that's amazing pressure actually
listening to old Weezer like yeah
I should mention this because YouTube
deleted his video from YouTube from
YouTube saying that it was like medical
misinformation and he's like what wait
what was medical this song Let's go
Brandon yes like people are listening to
this song for medical advice
they're like well I was gonna get
vaccinated but then I heard let's go
Brandon right that does not follow yeah
no it's it's it's it's it's very obvious
the left controls cultural institutions
by force they wouldn't if they didn't
own these platforms they would not
survive exactly this music this you know
it's it's really funny when um we did a
segment the other day talking about
bands like Rage Against the Machine in
The Offspring and I go back and I look
at some of this music I I was looking at
I think Gone Away by The Offspring
reached the Billboard Hot 100 number one
it was like a number one single it is a
really good song but then you look at
the video for it and it's like it
doesn't get a lot of play but then you
look at some other pop music with
billions of views and I'm like it seems
to me that back in the day they were
artificial officially propping up songs
that people didn't really care for yeah
that's how the industry worked and now
that people have the ability to choose
you can see what kind of music people
really do like well that's what happened
is record companies would send out the
songs to the radio stations and the
radio stations would have to play those
songs a certain number of times a day
interesting they would push them yeah I
didn't realize that yeah they would have
like all manufacturers the old-time
influencer model of radio interesting so
it's like it's crazy to think about that
a lot of the songs we heard in the 90s
was just a record label being like we
want to sell this song it's like do
people like there were some bangers
though you know closing time yeah
glycerin yeah also good or Glycerine I
don't know
Green Day the whole but were they were
they really the best or was it just
that's all you could get no I hated
Green Day yeah Green Day wow wow that's
a little messed up not the best okay
green is the worst I agree yeah and they
had their they got a they got a Broadway
show I think green really what didn't
they yeah there was like a musical there
was a Green Day Musical that grosses me
out I don't like that huh I wonder it's
really funny because we talked about
this before too with um American Idiot
I remember I could be wrong about this
but my understanding was that they had
produced some garbage pop album with
like acoustic songs and then people
racked on them for like not being Punk
so then they scrapped the album and then
made American Idiot and they were like
there's an original Broadway cast
recording of what American Idiot oh of
course right it's political because it
was a uh it was a musical Tim the look
of genuine confusion on your face why
would they allow that in 2009 it uh
premiered at Berkeley Rep oh it won a
Grammy gross and weird don't like that
wow yeah record company Grammys I hate
all that stuff yes literally just
patting themselves on the back anytime
the industry gives itself an award it's
also an opportunity so that you could
get up on stage and tell everybody how
proud you are to have had an abortion
yep right yep murdered my child yeah and
you're all horrible people at home maybe
not I don't know I was saying Grammys
who did that oh there was an Oscars that
was awesome I'm sorry I get confused
with the celebrities awarding themselves
yeah exactly
cells in the back they're all doing it
all the time which reminds me we're
going to be doing the official Tim cast
award exactly oh who's going to win oh
oh it's my award beautiful
I'd like to thank my abortion doctor
I shouldn't even joke about that I
literally just made myself
on the stage
and they should talk about how they
encourage their girlfriends to have
abortions or their wives have abortions
so that their careers could be that much
better without having the burden of
children
these not fathers could be applauded for
having a exterminated pregnancy this is
the exact why do we only celebrate women
who good point kill their children
opportunity you know what I mean single
argument I saw when people were hashtag
shouting their abortions every argument
I saw equally applied to deadbeat dads
yeah every single one was like well it
helped me get further along in my career
I wasn't ready for a child's account you
could say this about a guy who just
abandons his kids those are crazy
arguments too yeah like I wanted to have
a career and go to school and it's like
you can do that like you know someone
had to die like a person had to die it's
so emotionally manipulative here's what
they'll do you'll show a woman a
mammogram of what her actual child or
not a man I'm getting confused because
Planned Parenthood Planned Parenthood
claims they have mammograms but they
don't
um so that's always in my head when I
discuss about they literally have no
mammograms no not at the same they have
said they they do cut your boobs off
yeah yeah for sure but I'm sorry
mammograms so if you show someone an
ultrasound of what their child actually
looks like that's emotional manipulation
but if you convince women that they'll
just never achieve their dreams unless
they kill their baby that's reasonable
yeah that's fine yeah
it's insane yeah comes to me yeah
that's like a weird segue though where's
my Tim cast award yeah
best best hard segue into it we're
talking
about it seems like a pretty slow news
day to be completely honest like I was
reading the news and it was just like
everyone was kind of just twiddling
their thumbs it was a good day to drive
directly into the Sun
that worked out for you then sorry I
guess we're kind of just in this middle
period waiting for we have a direction
yeah well right now it's the red house
thing yeah The Rittenhouse trial is
interesting did you see uh you you guys
maybe you talked about it already and I
missed it but they were saying um the
people who were killed in that situation
cannot be referred to as victims that's
right right that's right
you know which is appropriate 100 I
totally agree so I had that tweet that
Donald Trump pinned on Twitter for a
long time where it was like the
writtenhouse thing like helped convince
me to vote for Trump and
it that's like like the left views it as
like it's proof of being far right or
whatever it's crazy though because it's
this this story with right now shows you
that left and right are meaningless
other than you either are an idiot who
believes fake BS or you care about facts
Destiny for instance leftist streamer
yeah was like the clearest case of
self-defense I've ever seen yeah right
yeah and then his argument with vosh
vosh said in the Marvel movies good guys
put their guns down it's like what yeah
but no no they don't and that's totally
fake and it was so perfect I mean it was
such an Abomination when they changed
Star Wars for example and made it so
that Han didn't know right first that
was the stupidest thing ever obviously
what makes him a good character is that
he's conflicted is that he I don't think
he was conflicted he was like I'm going
to shoot this man he does he does bad
things right there's like yeah so well
he was kind of a scoundrel yeah which is
a good thing about him and that's the
only I mean would Leah have fallen for
the good guy no no way she kissed her
brother that was a little weird
you know the funny thing about the Star
Wars when when she kissed her brother is
that they have the force right they have
like strong in the force so they had to
have known right you know when when
I wasn't it like with magnets
when he's like Vader's already Vader's
here already he can sense my presence or
whatever and then when Vader's like
search your feelings or whatever you
know whether he's your father oh my
goodness of course so there's no way but
maybe it's not maybe it's only if you're
looking for it you know if you're into
somebody you don't stop to think I need
to search the force for whether this is
my sister yeah I'm not gonna be your
sister well they have that app in
Iceland yeah they do you know
really yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
an app in Iceland where you can look up
if the person you're dating is actually
your cousin very small gene pool up
there yeah I can see that being
repurposed for a kink oh my goodness
well anyway back to Kyle Rittenhouse
um no yeah this will be interesting well
it's saying too because this is another
reason why it's so
dangerous to have a dialogue surrounding
guns in a country where a large majority
of the citizens have never handled a gun
and most of the people on the other side
of the gun debate have never seen one in
person I think oftentimes because you
turn the volume people don't realize the
unbelievable discipline which was
required for Kyle to literally only hit
his targets like he is in an urban
environment being chased on by a mob and
he only hit the people who were trying
to attack him people think that weapons
function as they do in the films where
anyone can just hit whatever Target they
want to shoot that's not easy it's not
easy and it's most and this is one thing
that anyone who knows anything about
Firearms will tell you when people ask
like why would you need 30 rounds why
would you need a 50 round magazine and a
handgun well the reason is because most
of the time you're not going to hit your
target especially if you don't train
very often especially if you're an
average person you're not in the
military or something someone who's been
tactically trained or shoots every day
you're probably going to miss a good
amount and also it can take more than
one bullet to take a person down so the
the fact that this kid was able to with
Precision hit only the people who are
trying to hurt him when he was being
chased on by an entire mob of people is
a testament
of adults is a testament to how
responsible he was he wasn't just out
there shooting his gun out like a maniac
he only hit people who were a direct
threat to his life even though an entire
mob was chasing him down well that's why
so the judge said you can call him
Riders looters and arsonists victims
right the the amount of misinformation
in this story it's it's mind-boggling
it's infuriating because I expect it
when it comes to politics yeah but this
is so crazy man
go on Twitter
and look at like what these these these
Progressive tick-tockers or tick tockers
are saying about it and they're like a
white supremacist mass murderer who took
a gun across state lines like that is
none of it is true
is shortly after that I think it was in
what was it September of 2020
um the Biden campaign came out with an
ad where they called writtenhouse a
white nationalist a white nationalist
they could just say that about anybody
Biden called him that Biden said that in
a campaign ad and the family came out
and said we're going to sue you I don't
know what happened with that but when
you have the man who becomes president
making up lies to win political
elections lies about a teenager lies
about to try to damage their reputation
he's trying to protect his community
yeah and himself well and it's funny too
one of the reasons one of the most
obvious tells from the get-go that this
was not the kind of mass shooting
situation the left was trying to make it
out to be is people on the left were
actually referring to gun laws that they
thought were broken every single time a
shooting occurs they pretend that there
were no laws in place to prevent it
because then they have to acknowledge
the fact that whatever new laws are put
into place are just going to be
disobeyed by any psychopath who wants to
murder people anyway and so with
Rittenhouse they're saying he traveled
to a different state with a gun which is
illegal first of all that's not even
true but if it was if you really think
someone's a mass murderer you're not all
that concerned with the regulations they
broke transporting their gun it's all
they got exactly it's all they had this
is it's
crazy like man the the
it's been getting bad
you know I know I know I go oh Civil War
and all that stuff but I'm like dude it
is really bad so I follow a bunch of
progressive YouTubers and stuff and just
to see the amount of fake news they
peddle I realized something today
because like a lot of them I watch they
don't have sources
or they'll use broken sources they won't
seek out they'll find a source that has
the information they prefer
of course and then they'll show that as
their Source like slate.com and
Huffington Post and I use CNN as often
as I can I do I do use Daily Mail fairly
often but I try to use CNN I try to use
CBS I try to use NBC and then I'm always
fact checking and trying to be like are
there are there whenever I'm looking at
a story I'll try and find like four
different versions of the same story and
then go through them and see what their
sources to make sure that they're not
doing closed loop sourcing
I think that makes a lot of sense to do
it that way because otherwise you're
just not sure who's reporting off of
what and where they got their
information so if I can verify something
I choose to use CNN because I think it's
funny yeah I'm like and use their own
sources against them 100 well what if
Cena gets it right they deserve to be
used to Source also true on those rare
occasions and more importantly when
they're like gamble made up this story
about writtenhouse like that's that's
the New York Times yeah so I I tweeted
uh the people were tweeting with the
Alec Baldwin thing and they were like
you know Alec Baldwin did nothing wrong
and they said Kyle Rittenhouse should go
to prison and then I said Alec Baldwin
was a producer on the film who was
handed a load weapon didn't check
pointed at him and pulled the trigger
Kyle Rittenhouse was you know defending
was defending a bunch of businesses from
rioters who fled after being attacked
trying to put out a fire trying to put a
fire out as they're pushing it towards
the gas station and only fired when
fired upon and I get these leftists like
that never happened no one fired at him
and I'm like the New York Times reported
that the New York Times I pulled the New
York Times I show the photo where it
shows the circles muzzle flash and then
I paste it I'm like there's the image
here's the link and they're like oh
please if you go frame by frame you can
make anything up and there were there
were journalists on the ground covering
that stuff yeah and we were all watching
that it was all it was so clear
dude if there was great coverage of that
yeah people people made a good point the
other day if Rittenhouse gets uh
convicted there'll be riots if he's
acquitted there'll be rights and it's
not going to be from the right of course
like the left is going to write no
matter what because if they do convict
him he's not gonna get the worst
possible charges probably I mean for a
while I I was saying life but after
seeing this judge I like this I don't
think so well yeah exactly here's the
thing part of why this is such an
important battle for them is because
they want people to be terrified of the
mob and they want you to know that if
you defend yourself you're going to be
punished for it and so if this kid goes
down simply for defending himself the
message that sends to the American
public is if there are people in your
community burning down businesses and
attacking innocent people you mind your
business or if you're the person who
they want to kill you let them kill you
because if you don't we'll destroy your
life anyway so the thing about
Rittenhouse really is that
if he hadn't defended himself if he had
allowed the mob to kill him as 33 people
were killed this past summer none of us
would know his name right but because he
defended himself he's front page news we
would know his name we might like but
the average person we wouldn't be
talking about it the people who killed
him when their trial date come up that
came up that wouldn't be a new story
they wouldn't be pushing it as hard as
they're pushing the Rittenhouse Story
the media wouldn't be talking about
expressing the Arbury story The Ahmad
Arbury Story the young man oh right
killed in Georgia by um who's a black
man killed in Georgia by three white
guys in a pickup truck he was jogging he
was jogging yeah I was under
construction he was jogging inside a
house under construction
um yeah so that was another sort of like
uh what in Boots Right double check I
need to double check on this yeah I
think he was wearing boots but the the
mob has to use might because they have
no moral Authority at all and so they
have to use shame and all of those
things that's the only way that they
have power there's a there's an
occupying force in our culture and
government that is represents a fringe
faction of ideologies and it's because
of the cowardice of so many people that
they're able to get away with what they
do exactly and these mobs are their
militant Wing I I am so I have to say
I'm so intrigued by this judge by him
saying this before the trial even gets
underway what is he thinking what is he
trying to convey because he's being
surprisingly based which is well you
know what he said he said that if the
defense could back up their claims that
these were arsonist writers and looters
and they could for sure call them that
they just have to back it up which I
think is
um pretty possible to do they were
literally trying to set a gas station on
fire that night right in Connecticut
yeah the prosecutor argued they were
just trying to obstruct a road with a
flaming dumpster and the judge is like
that's okay yeah the judge goes he's
like he's like excuse me it's just arson
come on as if there's a Zone where
that's acceptable and they're like well
you know he wasn't there
yeah this is this is what we we have to
look forward to well there was another
man too who I don't think it was in
Kenosha we reported on it at
post-millennial Mia cathell wrote about
it at length
um there was a man who was defending his
shop and his elderly father against a
mob of looters and this man shot one of
the looters who was trying to break into
the shop he was then
um condemned vilified mobbed online all
of that stuff for being a racist because
the man he shot was black he was simply
he was defending his shop against these
people and he later killed himself whoa
oh my because it was so traumatizing and
horrible
nobody says his name and I can't even
remember his name which is she's
horrible there's a story out of uh
Philly that never got really big play at
all because there was no interest from
anybody to cover it but during the
height of the riots I there was a local
gun stories to go to and the guy told me
this is crazy he told me that they got a
warning from the ATF that people were
going to try and loot gun stores during
the riots right later on I heard a news
story that three guys tried breaking
into a Philly gun store and one of them
well I think one of them was shot and
killed and like someone might have may
have been injured I can't remember but I
put two and two together I was like whoa
I remember so what happened was the guy
was sleeping in his gunshot that's right
ATF probably called him
told him because the other gun shop told
me he was also sleeping in a store right
and then he's sitting there armed and
someone breaks in and Bam
no one that's a way to save lives is to
prevent people from stealing your guns
yeah yeah but no no to a person thought
it was going to be a good story probably
to be like hey look what happened and
the left certainly didn't want to say
hey the black lives matter people are
trying to steal guns now oh gosh there
is that video though where they break
into a gun store and then just start
taking everything have you seen that I
haven't seen that dude it was crazy last
year can you believe it's been almost
two years since we've been under uh
we've been living under fascism I didn't
realize I had no idea that's crazy right
when would you say the fascism started
the lockdowns March 13th 2020. yeah is
that it the date so we're about a year
and a half in that's when New York
City's school closed the school's closed
wow and I remember distinctly because I
had pulled my son out of school because
there were lice oh nice it wasn't the
covet that did it it was the life
and then I was like I'm not having
lockdown with the lice yeah that's not
gonna work tonight let's let's talk
about this story that you guys have at
the post millennial because it's
horrifying and probably get us in
trouble on YouTube but we should talk
about it let's do it it didn't get the
high school in trouble on social media
so it'll get us in trouble for we'll get
in trouble for talking about it I did it
yeah oh it was right so we're on social
media from post-millennial investigation
underway after Kentucky High School
hosts dragged pageant featuring male
teens in lingerie giving lap dances to
staff oh my gosh I didn't realize the
people what dancing were miners yes I
didn't know I'm serious I didn't when
people were
sharing the story I was like oh that's
horrible and disgusting I didn't realize
that it wasn't like they brought people
in to do something inappropriate in a
high school they actually had minors
doing this dude that's like they had
that's like that's like prison stuff
that's like fun stuff yeah that should
be hard time those are minors you're
that you're having give lap dances yep
there are uh that's a sex offender
absolute state of these United States
what is happening right now oh my gosh
it was it was Jacob Gardner I just want
to say that the man who uh oh jailed
herself yeah yeah we talked about it oh
that's right that's right that's right
yeah yeah he was the guy who was in
Omaha yeah that's right and they they
attacked his restaurant yeah the guy was
choking him out right well not only do
we have those kind of stories we also
have this where at a high school they're
having minor males give lap dances to
okay that is so unbelievable no it's not
come on I mean you're right it's
unbelievable it's so the audacity of
these people first they shut the schools
down for over a year and whine and
complain anyone tells them that they
have to go back into the classroom and
do their job and then on top of that
they happen to be pushing all this CRT
stuff this sort of kinsian perverse
sexual education curriculum with all
these gross modern ideas in it and then
before this story breaks we're seeing
think pieces about how parents don't
really have rights we need to allow the
teachers to do their job in general
saying that as well the Attorney General
yeah they affirmed that he was going to
continue the investigation into angry
parents
Association has basically rescinded
their original letter from September
that's what they need to be
investigating of course not the rampant
sex abuse problem in public schools it's
also not as if this is an isolated
occurrence you see sexual abuse is a
common phenomenon Public Schools this is
this is just a practical right this is
like just the Practical from the
genderqueer health class exactly did you
see that book that was going viral today
we're weird yeah yeah where show the
president touted this book it is
disgusting if you look at it I saw
someone
sex acts in it yeah and it's not just
written down it's pornography it's wrong
it's it's very visual
so it's it's got very pictures of minors
engaging in in adult activities yeah yep
so this this stuff is unbelievably
disgusting I did a video a couple weeks
ago that I spent a long time researching
and it's about a gentleman named Kinsey
by the name of Kinsey yeah and he is
known as the father of sexology Dr
Kinsey he basically High School their
dog was named Kinsey oh wow yeah I know
he to like shame the guy I hope so no it
was it was just they thought it was
funny I mean a lot of people name their
dog Sheamus it's a very common thing
when I say my name is James
anyway yeah so so Kenzie
is basically the person who he is the
sexology what Freud was to psychology I
mean he basically developed this field
in his accolades went on to develop
sikhists which sets standards basically
and largely influences Federal standards
for sexual education or what we call
comprehensive sexual education in the
United States so Kinsey this is all the
way back in the 40s right he was doing
these surveys on human sexuality and he
published a document saying hey
what we learned from our surveys is that
people are not following the sexual
morals and Norms that Society has
attempted to foist upon them now his
findings were faulty in Abraham Maslow
who was by no means a religious
conservative came forward and said this
study was horribly done because he
oversampled prisoners homosexuals
prostitutes and it was also
self-reported that was the thing Maslow
had the problem with that was
self-reported who in the 40s is going to
tell you their sexual history the veres
of sex practices exactly yeah and so on
top of that there were also there was um
the official story from the Kinsey
Institute and they've changed their
story but the official story is that
there was a child sex abuser who came to
Kinsey who Kinsey taught how to use a
stopwatch to time his sexual abuse of
the children so that he could publish in
his documents and in the Kinsey mail
report there is a data table showing
data I'll put it this way so I don't get
your channel deleted that you could only
possibly have if you sexually abused the
child to get it so so and so this is the
guy who's upon which we have based the
field of sexology and his disciples went
on to find Seekers and
it's all done with the assumptions that
he forwarded in our culture and the guy
was a pervert who was enabling
pedophiles
well we're still enabling and we're
still enabling pedophiles my point is I
mean here it is here it is in Kentucky
well but that's my point people see
things like this in they think it just
started but the seeds were sewn for this
a very long time ago you had an uh 1980s
in Time Magazine Pomeroy one of Kinsey's
co-authors saying that he thought that
incestuous behavior between adults and
children is not necessarily harmful I
was just on record wow wow yikes just on
record so this is what we're starting to
see translate into these schools exactly
that's that's how it kind of comes
together for people exactly I mean you
build your house on Sand it falls apart
right and if your house is built upon
these horrific immoral sexual attitudes
you get horrific immoral sexual outcomes
yeah that includes sexual abuse it's
funny because it feels like
conservatives have been asleep at the
wheel for a long time very long time
Democrats have mastered their ground
game they've they've really dominated
for a long time but the the Democrats
are in charge of Corporations they're in
charge of
um political power they have all the
cultural power they have the academic
and institutional power so they have
control over it all of these Avenues of
power in the United States and they're
using it to bludgeon the rest of us and
they're acting as though they are
speaking out against Power because
that's the language that they have used
to gain power we're speaking against
this overarching authoritarian you know
totalitarian moral code and now they're
using those exact same tactics to
destroy us Amen on purpose one because
all along to them power was just new
speak for thing we don't like right
because it's blatantly obvious that
they're the people in power so whenever
they say your publication attacks the
downtrodden and you punch down they say
this about humor they dislike all the
time it's punching down and everything
right exactly what they mean by down is
thing we like doesn't matter whether
that thing is empowered or not
what matters is they like it so they say
it's it's powerless or it represents the
powerless but it has it has nothing to
do with actual power dynamics it just
happens to be something that they like
and so they know it's it's better Optics
the seat of power is corporations yeah
and we're seeing that so fully we say
that online all the time you know like
the corporations do what they're told
that's how it appears
um and then they take all of that and
they foist it on the rest of us I was I
was looking up
um Chief diversity officer it's just
impressive as as the religious
authorities used to be I would say
that's worse or I'll say more yes way
worse you know like religion deeply
influential in a lot of ways but when I
was growing up nowhere near the power of
massive corporations no but the church
told us that they had that kind of power
the left told us that this moral
Authority was bad and that we needed to
fight against it and it was really just
people voting together well and you know
why because and it was communities it
was communities helping each other evil
always calls for tolerance and then when
it's ascendant it calls for compliance
and that's exactly what we're seeing
yep and uh it's a state of uh you know
well it's interesting when you look at
these corporations oftentimes they'll
make decisions about who they should
hire or fire what kinds of and when I
mean who they should hire a fire I mean
in mass like what you know number of
minorities do we need at this company do
we need to hire more women of color more
transgender people Etc should we
apologize for this commercial should we
try to
bring more diversity Etc they make
decisions like this on the basis of a
small handful of people at Twitter
tweeting at them because they think that
means there is a large number of people
or a large majority of people out there
who are going to boycott them if they
don't obey right so one of their
employees does something wrong and then
a couple people tweet at them they lose
their minds because the quote-unquote
consensus on Twitter is one way but
what's really important I just want to
say one more thing according to a Pew
survey
Twitter uses our plus 15 Democrat so it
would be one of the most Democratic
states in the country and that's
basically what they're doing you
wouldn't quite call it market research
but that's where they're getting a lot
of their data on what the American
people want I looked up Chief diversity
officer yeah that's a new thing it sure
is and uh Wikipedia's first entry goes
back to 2008.
and if you look up CEO it goes back to
2002 obviously because CEO has been
around for a long time diversity officer
is basically Communist Party member
right so the Chinese Communist party has
amen they have their party member in all
these businesses that assert Authority
and control over how you fall in line
now what they're starting to do is
they're starting to make Chief diversity
officers and it is the most insane thing
you can ever imagine it's a good point
it's like a tumor because think about it
what is the chief executive officer do I
mean they run the show they make
executive decisions right on everything
now the chief operating officer executes
on those things is in charge of the
advantage of the data they did
everything runs the operations then you
have Chief marketing officer head of
marketing Chief technology officer then
you have like content officers you have
high ranking positions based around
specific tasks for companies
what would so so content Chief content
officer we know what that does they make
they manage oversee content what is
content well it's a thing you're making
and selling Chief marketing officer
they're selling the product to everybody
Chief Operating officers running the
company they're doing things that make
money that matter Chief diversity
officer the chief hospitalizing ideology
and the chief diversity officer has to
make sure that racism remains front and
foreign you have to make sure that
there's constantly racism problems in
the company otherwise you have no job
because there's no point of the chief
diversity officer other than maintaining
their position yes exactly that's why
it's not making Human Resources a bigger
Department yeah well this is why Thomas
Soul said never put activists in charge
of solving a problem of course the
activist has nothing to do with the
problem yeah they're going to find
things that seem problematic when they
aren't because that's the bread and
butter I learned this uh when I worked
for these nonprofits a good non-profit
puts itself out of business hey here's
the problem we want to solve a problem
we made it made a bunch of money we
campaigned for problem problem is solved
goodbye everybody have a nice day they
never never well once I think it was
clear a couple of years ago when they um
investigations started into these
not-for-profits they're like the was it
the
The Race for the Cure whatever that one
was the pink ribbon yeah it turned out
that some massive amount 95
of the revenue went to further the
operation itself not to do anything
yeah so it was all for administrative
costs right so it wasn't to further the
mission it was to maintain the company
it's supposed to be like a good
non-profit is 90 charitable 10 costs I
think it's fair to say because I've
worked for some nonprofits where it's
like 50 50 and you're like well look if
paying the salaries of people running
the company is consuming amount of
resources
and it's high I still think it's fine if
it's 95 to five too much
and especially for a very large
non-profit where the executive director
is getting paid millions of dollars
exactly I mean it's thinkable that in
certain circumstances based on the kind
of activism they're engaged in it might
be more complicated so the
administrative cost might be higher but
95 is absurd it's really just all about
the gala so that everyone feels good it
goes back to those celebs giving
themselves Awards again
exactly big old Circle and then these
are the drugs and then these are the tax
breaks that are taken by the big
multi-billion dollar corporations that
Elizabeth Warren wants to pay their fair
share but they're giving all their money
to the gallery it's it's it's not so
easy you know I'm learning this
especially people think that a lot of
these ultra wealthy individuals will
start a non-profit and just hide their
money or an LLC it's not that easy to do
but they find these workarounds where
they can do certain things there's
there's there seems like I know it's not
easy I've looked into it well no because
we're doing two non-profits yeah no I
know I'm on the board of one of them
right uh and so I'm talking to the our
accountant about like okay so I want to
get this ball rolling on truth and media
we want to start fact checking what can
we do like how much can we do and
they're like here's your limit you can
only do so much you'll need to find
other donors and I was like oh wow all
right interesting there you go yeah so
it's not it's not like you can just hide
all your money or write it all off but
there's there are things that these
companies do where it's like you'll
create 10 non-profits and then they have
the money as like a Whirlpool shuffling
around which basically cleans them of
tax liability and things like that so
it's like if you got 10 non-profits then
you can donate a little bit to each one
then they can all done it to one then
you can pay yourself a 10 million dollar
salary so there's so crazy things when I
was doing when I was doing Theater Arts
um because one of the things people
would do is start their own Theater
Company right so that they could do
their own work which I did that too but
other people got uh they created
not-for-profits out of their theater
company so that they were charitable
organizations when it was really just
like a couple of people from Barnard or
whatever who wanted to do theater
projects and then they would get all of
their families to donate and their
families companies to donate so that all
of this money would just pour in
well we were talking about Chief
diversity officer so I want to get over
to our next story here
uh you guys are gonna love this one oh
boy we have a new woke ad actually we
got a couple but we're gonna start the
start with this one I'm so excited from
from Libs of tick tock we have a Doritos
commercial oh and it says Doritos just
put out this ad for your viewing
pleasure I will now play the ad for you
and then we will discuss
this will break you oh my God
all right not everybody's watching so
I'm going to translate for you guys it's
in Spanish an old lady and a bunch of
people are looking at a shrine and there
is a photo of an old man it's just my
brother I miss you so much
smoke and a ghost appears
what's up family how are you guys
all right all right now all of a sudden
another man has just emerged behind I
think what would you call them are they
was that a lich is he a little oh yeah a
what a lich what's a lich yeah I don't
know what a little dead so um it's like
a zombie but not mindless right oh I
think he's a spirit because this is
based on the movie Coco yeah oh is it
yeah which is based on the idea of the
Day of the Dead right so he's he's a
he's a uh
yeah yeah he's a he's a he's a
poltergeist yeah he's a he's not a
poltergeist no maybe he'd be a
poltergeist if he was but hold on okay a
man has just emerged from behind him he
removes his hat he removes his hat
what
[Music]
okay
I thought he'd be alone forever and then
they hug so look at his hands he's got
his arms are bones uh so weird is that
is that what Coco is I guess yeah yeah I
think I think that's that is very
similar to the style yeah
okay let me I just gotta say right off
the bat Doritos what what does this have
to do you know guys I really want I
really want some chips yeah I don't know
I saw this commercial I'm not gonna eat
that that high glycemic garbage garbage
hold on hold on I don't I'm I would I
got no issue with a PSA about respecting
people who love anybody or whatever or
they're dead yeah exactly or the dead
remember but just I what I can't
understand is why they summon a dead man
who then also brings with him his Undead
gay partner yeah and why that is selling
chips corn chips yeah yeah you eat corn
chips if you're dead maybe if you're
dead I mean you also aren't supposed to
have relations if you're dead I think
you're dead
so many questions is this what they
think the afterlife is like like you're
a skeleton but you have a mustache he he
just he wasn't gay in life and then
after he died he came together with the
family my take on it was that he was too
ashamed
that he was that he was gay and so now
he's able to say that because he's dead
have you guys ever seen the movie The
Others no no Nicole Kidman no really no
sorry it's an old movie I'm gonna spoil
it but it's really good if it's old
that's fine basically it's like this
old-timey like 1800s or whatever and
weird haunting things keep happening and
you know like doors are opening and
stuff and then like they see they see a
little girl and they're like freaking
out and there's ghosts and then it turns
out that actually they're the ghosts oh
that's crazy and the weird things
happening were the living people doing
stuff and Nicole Kidman just couldn't
like reconcile the fact that she's like
a ghost or whatever and so I'm like I'm
imagining a horror film like that but it
turns out like at the end like the twist
was that the ghost was gay the whole
time
I'm just like I don't under it's it's
it's weird because they're weird it's
not thematically making sense well
they're gay and they're attracted to
dead people that's another thing
technically each of those guys is more
of the mainstreaming of Kink yeah yeah
right
it's recently a uh there was a there was
a an advice letter in slate magazine
about someone wrote in saying that their
Kink was necrophilia oh my gosh that is
disgusting why can't we just start
saying the word perversion again we have
to like it's not a kick that's a
perversion basically answered that
that took like a second to really sink
in with me but wow oh boy yeah cool with
this so what what a world we're in this
is a Doritos commercial
it's been around for a while
like where you know companies are trying
to this is the thing about a chief
diversity officer right they're betting
on selling their product based on yeah
ideas
too they're betting on selling they're
betting on selling more Doritos to woke
people and betting that conservatives
don't care yeah conservatives don't care
and you know and that's part of it too
is conservatives for the most part are
just like meh I still like to read yeah
whatever
we gotta start filming skits because we
can make a great one where it's like we
just make a really ridiculous religious
commercial and then it's selling
something like you like you know lug
nuts for your tire right it's like it
has nothing to do a dad comes like comes
back home to like meet his son and his
son's like you weren't there for me and
Mom and then he's like but thanks to
these Myers lug nuts I was able to
finally make it home he's like Dad and
they hung and then the ghost was too
much a ghost comes out of the chips a
ghost comes out of the chimney and the
closet at the same time and explains to
them that he has a partner in the
afterlife
yo that's yeah I would say that's a bit
of a strange commercial
yeah not a big fan I'm not either I'm
not a fan of the commercial do we have
to at all that though do we have to call
an exorcist no listen that happened to
me if this is what this is coming for
everything it's interesting too because
so several years ago I was uh walking in
I don't know where was it somewhere in
Manhattan and the subway station there
were all these advertisements and I was
with my son who at the time I think was
five and there was a huge ad of people
making out right it was just a it was
just a print ad but it was giant like
the subway the subway yeah and um my son
goes um
mom what's that an ad for like CPR
they're doing mouth come out yeah CPR
class and we looked at it for a while
and I said huh that's an ad for jeans
yeah and he was like what passing them
on apparently
he was like that is so peculiar and this
is like the five-year-old the
five-year-old it used to be that they
were selling us things with sex right
right and now they're selling us things
with their new religion it's like the
yeah it's all Family Guy is that joke
where it's like they're watching TV and
it's a bunch of beautiful women at a
pool and they're all drinking and
getting drunk and it's like drink our
beer if you do beautiful women love sex
with that South Park yeah
okay I know South Park did a version
where they keep going they're like yeah
I drink all these women drink
responsibly
absolutely I always think that too it's
like well you remember the ones then
they would have a boat and I was always
like I would drink the beer if it got me
the boat yeah but I know but it doesn't
well so this is this is one thing I
learned I went to Art School oh and I
took a media literacy Theory class and
one thing our professor did is he just
had us watch a bunch of commercials and
they almost never have anything to do
with the product ever the reason these
are weird is because they're clearly
pushing a specific ideology which is
pretty strange doing an advertisement to
like support a political cause that has
nothing to do with the product but
usually they want to sell people an
experience so the idea is you associate
their product with something positive so
he would show us in in particular these
uh Kraft mac and cheese commercials and
they were really Insidious because they
were playful but basically the moral of
every commercial was someone in your
family's betraying you like all the
commercials you wouldn't think it that
way watching them but you watch all the
commercials and it stacked up and the
punch line is always like someone in
your family secretly screwed you over to
get the macaroni
um creepy yeah it was actually really
good it was very funny sounds like my
family
macaroni and cheese what's interesting
is commercials always try to sell you an
experience and then the product is
secondary I remember when I was a kid
hold on I have to tell the story real
fast because this is something that was
very Vivid for me because they used to
sell these like rocket pops the freezer
pops and in these commercials the world
was always black and white it was very
boring this kid is going to the fridge
nothing's going on it's highly
uninteresting you take out one of these
super cool rocket pops and you lick it
and the whole world is like in color I
was like six so when I actually finally
convinced my mom to get these stupid
rocket pop things I was like this is
gonna be amazing and I licked it and I
was like oh everything I know is alive
because nothing happened yeah it's very
sad because I worked on a kid right oh
100 I remember they had commercials for
a drink called I believe it was called
Tang yeah in the commercial they'd like
put the straw in the drink and then the
camera would go through the straw and
they'd be like
chimpanzees on surfboards and stuff it
was crazy and so my brother Pat was like
you know like I actually looked inside I
got to get tangots and I looked inside
and like that's literally what's
happened I was like no dude no way I was
pretty little I was like no wait so then
I was walking
at the park and I saw this like crumpled
up like gross empty tank with the straw
in it I was like looking through it I
was like
I was like there's no there's literally
not a single chip I would have been fine
with one chimpanzee surface that's not
though what the astronauts took to space
didn't they have tang in space so
astronauts did have those pouches
yeah but it's not a you know just to
what you were saying before about
pushing a political idea on us it's not
a political idea that they're pushing
it's cultural well it's both yeah I
suppose well it's it's both I think I
think it's different I think politics I
think politics can they the two can have
an impact on each other but I think
what's being pushed is a cultural
transformation it's so hard for me to
separate the two because disrupting the
family is a huge strategy for political
control we have another app yeah but
it's culture we have another we have
another app culture we have another ad
brought to you by Libs of tick tock this
time Twix sponsoring this Halloween ad
that uh for your viewing pleasure we
will now play presents bite-sized
Halloween
[Music]
hi
[Applause]
I'm your new Nami I don't
got the appropriate response when a
witch shows up a witch that's right I
guess at least a witch parents seem to
think you do she broke into the house
whoa
she operated she was jogging Tim other
than black in Boots oh exactly
charcoal
why are you all dressed up it's not
Halloween yet
can I help you are you a good witch or a
bad witch do you want to find out there
are no good witches so
you want to find out okay you buckled
I'm still wearing my princess dress do
you want to wear why is this kid getting
into the car with a stranger
also I like how they it wasn't obvious
enough he's wearing a princess dress he
has to they both have to say it out loud
that's what it's about it also wasn't
obvious that he was a boy princess
you look like a girl why are you wearing
dressing like this
just weird you look weird your Nanny
looks weird you guys are both weird
right serious I want to be friends with
that kid
she's just child seriously hurt that
child some child abuse going what is
happening we should go she read too much
kids and she knows she committed her
foreign
what did she do to that kid bro you know
what what was that
I gotta clarify for everybody we have to
make the statement do not use your magic
powers to harm children physically
because they said things that you found
offensive that's right well think about
that ad I mean a lot of people are like
it's grooming children I'm like it's a
kid wearing a dress but it's more like
she physically harms a child for saying
mean things
I understand no one's Really Gonna cast
a wind spell and blow a kid into the sky
or something but we certainly do have
activists who hurt others for saying
things that they disagree with that is
happening all the time now apparently
that was selling Twix What yeah I didn't
know I have no no no desire to purchase
a candy cookie with caramel in it in any
capacity in fact I I I just want to get
raw steak not once yeah right yeah that
not once was I appetized
amazing is that it's a happy Halloween
commercial but the kid wasn't apparently
in a costume yeah what's that about I
don't know
was it after Halloween no it was it was
the kid the other kids said uh you look
weird and it's not Halloween yet why are
you doing daylight and everything oh
yeah yeah well I guess it isn't
Halloween yet the other thing is like
that chick didn't look weird at all a
child sitting alone in a house wearing a
princess dress watching TV there's no
parents left to strangers and then and
then like a stranger shows up and says
I'm the nanny and the kid's like I don't
know about that and they break into the
house and then so like yeah the kid
closes the door yeah so let's put all
kinds of really bad messages yeah I
would agree let's let's start from the
beginning
unsupervised unsupervised strong start
right a strange woman shows up and says
I'm your Nanny says no you're not I
don't need a nanny he just says I don't
need an Annie close the door so his
parents clearly have not conveyed to him
and Nanny is coming over he's getting a
nanny it's just not part of the story
she breaks in anyway right if the kid
doesn't let her in where are the parents
in any of this she did the same thing to
them
don't don't witches eat kids yes that's
what she's doing we have a culture that
is intentionally driving a wedge between
children and parents he's doing that on
purpose yep yep yep and now corporations
are on board with that as well 100
that's part of I mean when you look even
at the uh the Biden
Child Care thing he wants his whole
Administration wants children to be out
of the home Yeah by 3 P.M by three three
years old sorry not three p.m right they
want kids out of the home by three years
old being educated in state institutions
being run by teachers unions and
National School Board Association
members and they want the parents
somewhere else doing anything else and
not being connected to the kids or
paying attention to what their children
are doing or being taught this this ad
actually aligns really well with the
Loudoun County stuff that when they say
the parents have no right to their own
children yeah exactly yes sir they do
believe that they believe that fully 100
out to quote Michael malis again the
most quoted man on this show that's
right the most disturbing thing about
socialists is not that they think your
property is their property it's that
they think your children are their
property yeah and actually I talked to a
woman who
um as an American who was living in
Norway and she was saying that you know
how
in the U.S people are always like oh in
Scandinavian countries they have
everything right on they're really doing
it right she was saying that because
there are so many taxes paid and so much
of that goes to support children and
child care and family leave and all of
that that the citizens in Norway feel a
right to tell parents how to raise their
kids yeah not cool not cool I'd rather
have zero of your money and you get no
say in how I raise my family they're
Insidious that's why they want to do it
that way I think it's intentional
something interesting in this commercial
too is when the kid he says wearing the
dress makes me feel good yeah as if like
children should just be doing whatever
makes their feel yeah yeah I mean
there's a reason that children are not
supposed to just do what makes them feel
good we're supposed to learn how to grow
up and be productive members of society
and take care of ourselves take care of
the people we love it's like bad
obviously bullying is a bad thing but to
kill a child well I don't know
when she runs she's like let's get out
of here first of all to hurt a child and
then run away like that's that's not a
good look so let's buy our candy it is
kind of witchy yeah exactly yeah it
really is but the thing about bullying
too is I don't know about you guys but a
lot of people have been bullied
throughout cultural pressure in in
school I was very badly bullied in
school and now I
I don't give a flying anything of what
anybody says about me at any point yeah
I mean what's the advantage of
disadvantage you're struggling for
yourself everybody who cares exactly and
so I think to a certain extent uh trying
to protect kids from every conceivable
confrontation is bad we shouldn't do
that kids need to figure out how to
navigate these situations oh 100 I
wonder chat with you on that I wonder if
there are kids who will see this and
then think that they can attack somebody
you know what I mean
like I understand Magic's not real but
the message was clearly that he was
physically harmed and even says will he
be coming back and she's like I don't
know probably she's like yeah probably
imagine if the equivalent was she just
picked the kid up and threw him like
over a fence or something exactly at a
certain point I think uh I think we're
gonna start seeing kids just feel shame
for being straight and gender conforming
yeah it's it's okay okay what if what if
a little boy wants to play with trucks
and wear pants and is into girls
they are targeting boys there was an
insurance company that had to take down
and match because there was a little boy
who was running through a house being
joyful wearing a dress trashing
everything they took down this ad
because it gave people the impression
that they would be covering this kind of
damage to a house they're like well it's
not correct this is not true they are
trying to get boys because like Abigail
schreyer talks about girls are
exceedingly susceptible to this boys are
not a boy wearing a skirt in a Twix
commercial might convince a little boy
that this is a normal thing to do well
take a look at the thing I liked about
that insurance commercial let me show
this thing real quick yeah so this is
from Instagram it's something that I
actually saw when I was browsing Reddit
it's called folks health and it says
folks health is rewriting the script for
lgbtq plus Healthcare get hormone
replacement therapy delivered to the
comfort of your home no barrier no
Stigma that doesn't seem smart well I
don't know about the legalities of this
I I know that prescription medication
you have to get at a pharmacy so I don't
know if they can deliver prescription
medicine I have no problem with that my
concern here is are there going to be
safeguards to make sure that underage
you know uh exactly individuals children
are not using the system to
self-medicate without approval from
their doctors
I'm not saying they are I'm just saying
like we're seeing active promotion
you get ads for everything and I think
all of it's bad like I remember there's
commercials for every drug and they're
like call your doctor and see if this
drug is right for you and I'm like no
why I feel fine yeah
sometimes I want to try it I'm like I
will call the doctor this commercial I
think I think it was Lunesta I remember
you know very well the butterfly yeah
no what that's that's was and it was
like call your doctor so it was a sleep
aid right the issue is when you have
major Pharmaceuticals being like we want
to sell a drug and whether you're a
minor or not they're telling people to
buy their drug I've never been a fan of
that whether it's for hormone therapies
or not someone could call and be like
hey I'm feeling these symptoms and they
could be like here's some drugs right
when people not everybody has chemically
imbalanced uh depression not everybody
has bipolar disorder some people get
depressed because of literal social
problems that could be solved by going
to a community Gathering going jogging
exercising and the problem is when you
tell people that they say things like
you're you're undermining my illness or
you're you're downplaying it there are
people who say things like yo if you're
depressed just go for a jog and it's
because jogging has been yeah to
alleviate depression but some people do
have medical issues that result in
chemical depression now I I I don't
think we're talking about those people
if you go to a doctor if you're feeling
bad and they diagnose you with a
chemical imbalance or something then by
all means get the treatment you need
yeah but for a lot of people it is good
advice just to go and and feel better
and get some sunshine and get some
sunshine but guess what
if our school companies got to sell you
know they gotta sell I thought it was
interesting that pharmaceutical
companies are allowed to sell on TV but
hard alcohol companies for a long time
were not allowed to
sell their products on TV that's why we
only have beer commercials yeah it is
kind of crazy to advertise
Pharmaceuticals on television that
should be something a doctor prescribes
to if they think it could work for you
like the idea that you fish for
customers I also and why don't we have
weed advertisements on TV I will point
out the the hilarity though of like me
being served an ad for this because ads
are always targeted it probably has to
do a lot with like the stories we pull
up to be completely honest they're like
Tim has too much testosterone we need to
give him on semester good well I've been
eating a lot of steak no for real like
too much steak no for real for like the
past week I've had like steak for
breakfast and steak for dinner oh that's
awesome because I went to a farm and I
was like I would like a cow and then
they just like hit me a big bag don't
have a cow man
tenderloin you know you've got a good
tenderloin you can't buy it in the
grocery store at this point why not my
like I keep being shy that I know this
is off topic but I keep being so shocked
at how much more my same groceries are
costing like six months ago my same two
bags of groceries were forty dollars
another 75 and I don't buy meat anymore
so it's just going up even though I've
taken all the meat out of my grocery we
went to a local farm and we bought
we did not buy that much meat the total
bill was like 500 bucks I mean it's good
farm fresh meat so it's going to be more
expensive anyway yeah we got some
tenderloins
yeah it is so good yeah we so we have
like Porter houses sirloins strip steaks
tender The Tenderloins were gone
instantly because those are just too
good it just melts in your mouth right
and then we try cooking T-Bone and
T-Bone's hard to get right porterhouse
is pretty good because porterhouse has
got some tenderloin on it the sirloins
are great the strip steaks were great
but the T-Bones we just couldn't get
yeah really yeah tough didn't know that
so we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
slow cook them but then we're gonna
we're gonna go out Fridays and there's a
local Farm like really close and I'm
just gonna be like I will take all of
your tenderloin just gonna buy all of it
up because that's that's just what you
want it's so good that's all you're
eating well I mean you know it's kind of
crazy because I've been I've been
cutting out all the processed garbage
and I think it was Jack busovic who
posted this photo
it was like life America before
processed food and it shows like normal
looking people yeah every like dude all
of the guys walking around have like six
packs they all look fine all the women
are thin yeah and then we introduce like
automatic donut machines right have you
ever seen the automatic pancake machines
no I've used them yeah at hotels you
press the button and then you watch this
like the pancake batter go down and then
there's two heated conveyor belts that
cook it and then just falls out and
you're like there's a fresh pancake kind
of cool wow I don't eat any of that
garbage so I've just been like steak
sounds good I make all that stuff I make
fresh I make crepes I make waffles I
make all that stuff at home sugar is bad
well you don't have to put sugar in it
no it is sugar what is pancakes
high glycemic that's only put all that
stuff in it no no it literally is it's
high glycemic yeah flower is high
glycemic well I'm still going to make
pancakes that's why I just eat grapes
I've been eating like just meat and I'm
not eating I'm eating no meat okay we
won't get into the meat space here let's
talk about why this stuff's happening
because someone actually chatted us
we've talked about ESG before it's
environmental social and governance
rating someone mentioned that uh as
we're talking about these this Twix
commercial and this um Doritos
commercial that the reason they're doing
this is because they're trying to reduce
their risk as they appear to creditors I
don't believe that
um ESG ratings are legit they're uh so
let me just read it says um in a ESG
writing measures a company's exposure to
long-term environmental social and
governance risks these risks involving
issues such as Energy Efficiency worker
safety and board Independence have
financial implications but they are
often not highlighted during traditional
Financial reviews investors who use ESG
ratings to supplement financial analysis
can gain a broader view of a company's
long-term potential so there are
companies that issue an ESG score yeah
they're woke right A lot of them like
most companies are and so if you're not
woke they'll say you have a very high
risk because oh what's that California
says you got to have a woman and a
person of color on your board and you
don't high risk of government
intervention bad score right so what do
they do
this other story that was breaking is
that a white male who was fired from a
North Carolina Hospital sued for 10
million dollars because they replace
them with a black woman and apparently
they fired a bunch of white male
Executives and hired that hired you know
black people to replace them and they
were and the jury was like you can't
just fire people for being white and
apparently this dude was on uh was
sitting in board meetings discussing
diversity and like how to help the
hospital and they fired him so what's
happening is for a lot of companies in
order to improve their ESG they're doing
all the green stuff great initiatives
and they're doing all the woke stuff
they won't have reduced risk but I
actually think this will backfire for
one Doritos with that commercial about
the ghost who turned out to be gay and
the Twix thing which has nothing to do
with cookies but it's like a boy horse
address
that's high risk like if I was an
investor
and I was like
well I have invested in companies I'll
tell you this I've invested in several
companies if they come to me and and I
say what's your strategy for like
growing the business and they go well
we're a company that manufactures you
know uh we we refined steel and in these
times steel is very expensive I'll say
wonderful wonderful well people need
steel okay so what's your plan for
marketing to go gender yes we're gonna
make commercials about people choosing
and I'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're gonna spend money say what that
could be a dividend or could hire more
people
to sell an ideology having nothing to do
with steel or could increase steel
production or could increase steel
production but but I I think there's two
things one some people are worried about
their scores this is basically social
credit social credit for corporations
yeah but some people just are buying
this this is this is religion now this
is the religion I mean there was a time
that's their tithe
well no this is this is their their
their their preaching there was a there
was a time when this country was
overwhelmingly Christian and people
would companies would be like I am not
going to offend the sensibilities by
putting a pentagram on something right
Magic the Gathering has a card called
Unholy strength it requires swamp energy
or black Mana as it's called is that
pretty sure and the character on the
card is like a guy leaning back with a
burning pentagram behind him in the
early 90s a bunch of religious groups
said hey this is offensive you can't do
that so they remove the art from
subsequent versions because there was a
time when Christianity had some swing
even Tipper Gore who was uh vice
president Al Gore's wife Democrat
Democrat who forced there to be explicit
warnings labels on records that she
thought were uh you know offensive to
her sensibilities as we lose our
judeo-christian moral framework and it
is supplanted by lack thereof
you get chaos exactly it is it is
turning into that yeah I mean like
that's something that's happening at
post-millennial even we're being
targeted by I think we talked about it
before we targeted by like these
activists who have no moral standing in
anything at all just say a whole bunch
of lies about us advertisers believe
them without looking into it at all
um it's funny because we're getting some
of that too are you getting it too yeah
I know that daily wire is getting it too
and revolver it has zero impact yeah
there's no impact whatsoever we're
working toward moving into a position
where that's going to have zero impact
we're getting close yeah it's just the
crazy thing is that um we've had some
issues where these woke activists have
contacted our advertisers and the
advertisers then have like an internal
meeting and they're like we don't
understand how Temple is controversial
and so I yeah I've had like
conversations where they're like they
were actually really worried at first
and then they looked at the site and
then did a did Research into you and
they were confused as to what the
activists were claiming and I was like
so what's their conclusion they were
like they made a mistake wow yeah well
you have people who are actually looking
into it a lot of advertisers a lot of
companies they don't even think about it
they just say okay we're out well yeah
we're good it's sad sorry it's very sad
because well it's because they're
they're not incentivized to right
because even if what the person is
saying about you is a total lie and even
if the advertiser no it's a a total lie
if they still think it's going to hurt
their bottom line to work with you
they're going to cut you loose right
or if they just don't care enough to
figure it out yeah
I think companies some companies are
starting to get wise to the fact that it
could be really bad for their business
so there was was it surf shark yeah
so I'll say two things for one one of
the sponsors of the show is a VPN
company virtual Shield we shot them out
all the time right but uh that's just
full disclosure because it has nothing
to do with them I'm only saying that
because I don't want this to be viewed
as a conflict of interest but surf shock
is a VPN and they sold out you guys
right they canceled on you because one
guy tweeted like Andy no was a bad
person right yeah and Andy no is a crime
reporter and this person commits crimes
here's what needs to happen
don't buy Doritos we won't we won't and
I want Doritos no I wasn't anyway but
Twix is off the menu and who and who
owns 2x Mars is it Mars yes I don't know
what else do they make everything stop
buying from these companies and surf
shark cancel your subscription to them
because the left does yeah and
conservatives for too long have just
gone along with this being like well
whatever I do my own thing I'll I'll
consume whatever product I want and
there hasn't been a lot of activism on
that side or even just on the side of
people who want to uphold things like
constitutional rights you know they're
not going around telling everyone what
to do and how to live their lives but
you can act with your own you know your
own pocketbook I got an idea here's the
activism that we need it's not about a
conservative it's not about being
independent it's not about being
libertarian here's here's the activism
the right really needs
stop eating sugar yes no no no I'm not
saying all sugar do keto I'm saying cut
out the cookies yes no more no more
twists garbage no more garbage you
should be when you go to the store I
tell you this man meat is expensive but
you you got to understand how much
you're wasting on these sugary coffee
drinks from Starbucks don't go to
Starbucks anymore why what do they have
to offer you a bottle of water okay fine
fine we've replaced all of our plastic
bottles with glass bottles that we we
put our own filtered water in now
because I'm like it's time to put up or
shut up I'm eating better I'm cutting
out the donuts the sugary garbage the
candy the all that crap
imagine this that photo that Jack
passovic posted of all of these people
walking around just in shape why because
food was real yes imagine that the left
can be sickly body positive or whatever
you want to call it
unwell suffering in their minds and the
one thing that you can do get in shape
start exercising cut out the candy cut
out the Doritos cut out the Starbucks
these are companies that are selling you
out and using your money to promote
ridiculous ideologies that don't even
sell their product so don't support them
well this is what this is what I'm
saying right it makes a lot of sense I
would not eat a Dorito right now if you
were to pay me for it why because I'm on
a diet and it doesn't mean I'm on a diet
to lose weight it means I'm on a
specific regimen of the food that I eat
for a specific reason yeah of course
fresh vegetables fresh fruits Meats I'm
not eating the garbage processed crap
anymore Yeah well yeah I don't have it
in my house like yeah I don't buy that
stuff for my kid I just don't want it I
mean you know when like we have sweets I
am I'm certainly never going to give up
sweets but I make cookies I make cookies
at home make it yourself yeah I made
banana bread muffins this week and we
were very excited it's funny because
conservatives won't really mobilize and
that way often I'm hoping that changes
I'm hoping we can convince people not to
purchase these products because that's
what needs to happen I just find it
hilarious that I mean the radical left
you know spent like I said you spent a
summer burning down cities people died
this is a very energetic and mobilized
group of people to put it kindly and
for all these cries you hear on the left
about conservatives are so dangerous and
they're gonna ride and kill people and
like we can't even get conservatives to
stop eating Twix bars like I don't think
this is what I'm saying that they're
that much of a threat unfortunately and
it's this is really really simple yeah
you don't need to remember a list of
companies not to buy from yeah you don't
need to go to the store and go oh Pepsi
are we boycotting Pepsi all you need to
do is say I eat farm fresh meats cheeses
and veggies yeah done and then when you
go to the store and you're like which
candy bar was I boycotting all of them
they poison your mind they're bad for
you yeah and also I I just wanna I'm on
board with that I just want to clarify
what I'm saying like not a threat I'm
saying conservatives do need to be a
threat in the sense that corporations
need to understand that we are a large
consumer block and their business can
suffer if they upset us if they walk all
over us if they try to insult us I'm
just thinking about a little
organization 100 but but not if not if
the approach is is you focus on yourself
no I mean to yes I mean to I mean to
boycott some of the com like some of the
companies that's true are taking these
behaviors not just the food companies I
mean it's easy it's easy to say I'm not
going to buy chips you know I mean
there's a lot of that kind of stuff I
was never buying anyway like I was never
gonna be I was never the target audience
for the Doritos ad because I've
literally never bought a Dorito it's
time to start uh look daily wire is
doing it and we're definitely doing it
they're way bigger than we are but
producing culture I think that's so
important we need to get to the point
where it's like no no don't don't watch
Disney you watch you know daily wire's
new show watch Tim cast but that's a
disk cast IRL yeah no more Disney dude
we've got some stuff we could produce
you know what I mean we got we got two
shows so far we have four four total
shows on the on Tim guest.com nice yeah
a fifth show is in production right now
where we're doing trials and auditions
and like test runs for a pop culture
show there's a lot of Pop Culture stuff
to talk about I mean we're doing uh
we're doing a lot of great podcasts at
post millennial we have this one cancel
this Dinesh D'Souza was just on
but here here's where we have we
actually I I think we apparently have um
Ari Hoffman doing an interview with uh
Donald Trump tomorrow
is that is good when it's on our Rumble
Channel this is more political content
right and podcasts are still very much
right-wing conservative whatever like
talk radio right that's why we're do we
do the cast Castle Vlog every day we
have an animator who makes silly jokes
like the the the shirt we just sold yes
step on snack and find out go to
timcast.com
actually do I still have it yeah yeah
here check it out step on snack and find
out this this amazing t-shirt you can
get by going to timcast.com and clicking
store and then scroll down it's on the
bottom we got to rearrange it better but
uh this will soon be up on the YouTube
as well this is from one of the Vlog
episodes we made where Kant who's the
animator had a t-shirt that Luke was
wearing and said step on snack and find
out something he made up and so we were
like let's make that shirt it's just
silly and funny look at that angry cute
little snake all angry about it and it's
just a silly gag it's meant to be silly
like you know step on snack and so
that's the Vlog is something
conservatives don't do what does the
daily wire have podcast podcast podcast
but now they have the movie now they're
doing a movie a movie yeah and they're
doing more sitcoms you have to start you
have to start somewhere so I'm actually
I'm actually I've been told Brandon is
that song being on the top of the charts
talking to people about comedy specials
we want a Tim cast exclusive comedy
special
Jim Brewer one did you say I I saw a
clip of it I don't know when it was from
but basically somebody sneezed in the
audience and he jokingly like set off an
alarm
we also uh speaking of culture there's
this really awesome channel that makes
animated political cartoons oh really
which I think is a great thing to be
doing right now it's called Freedom
Tunes if you guys just want to check but
Sheamus as I have told you you need a
pop culture version of that I've been
yeah no I want to do that we've been
I've been well
you and I should talk about after the
show got some ideas yeah but we also
there's another show I'm surprised you
didn't mention the sixth show timcast is
launching love Dr Sheamus that's right
we had a whole conversation about this
advice
here's the [ __ ] here's here's the pitch
it's Sheamus he takes calls and every
single time that someone calls asking
for advice he advises them to go to
church go to church or or if I mean
anytime I have a couple I'm thinking
like anytime anyone called me any kind
of problem with the relationship I'll be
like just break up
this is the headache for you can you
save the relationship yes you go to
church all right you go to church go to
church what you guys need to do is go to
church there you go no we love Dr
Sheamus I mean look I think it's got
staying power I think people would love
to watch something like that what if we
did like a full a full series like a 13
episode Arc of an animated show I would
love to do that you're kidding me I
would love to do that I've got like
ideas is up the Wazoo for Animated
Series yeah 100 let's do 20 minute
episodes yeah let's do it you guys heard
it here Tim committed that's right are
you joking yeah because we've been
talking how do you think Twitter should
be insults me because here's the thing
Tim's nice to be on camera right but
behind the scenes he's constantly
insulting me throwing things at me even
and I don't mean ideas no he's doing it
with the witch's hat yeah exactly the
other day I told Tim him and his Nanny
looked weird and he went right yeah and
there you were in your princess dress
feel good Tim good yeah
you should post your your profile
picture in the princess dress on Tinder
oh my gosh speaking of posting pictures
Lydia post that picture me on top of the
RV right sure and she tweeted it out I
don't know if she's going to Tweet it I
didn't actually care but I thought it'd
be funny to tweet like this is doxing I
didn't give you permission to post this
you know sorry sorry no no I didn't care
too but people people started commenting
and I guess the Tweet was performing
well so it started showing it to a bunch
of people including people have no idea
who I am and I was getting so many angry
comments from people like I have no idea
you are why am I seeing this in my feed
right now they were like viscerally
angry I was like someone's like who the
hell are you like why am I seeing this I
was like I don't like the algorithm I
don't know like I don't know why you're
saying this for you to see this it was
all because Lydia doxed me I had no idea
that my bullying could go onto Twitter
and cause trouble for Sheamus I got
canceled by Liz I'm very proud of myself
I was talking about doing um weekly
Comics like making your own version of
Shonen Jump yeah where we just get like
you know we publish one comic every week
and then we do like four different
series or something and then we can make
like a magazine with with Tales from the
inverted World we're actually making
books oh cool this is really exciting
yeah I'm so excited I think it's great
what you guys are doing too because I
love what daily wire is doing bringing
that out and they're doing sort of a
Hollywood style version of that but I
feel like what's needed is Indie culture
you know 100 percent
left woke Indie culture that's focused
on actually making funny things
beautiful things interesting real art
things you know
um this crazy like I was in so I've been
traveling a lot during the pandemic
um because screw everything like a tree
as well and I was recently in Nashville
at for a daily wire thing and we were
out on the
glorious Spectacular music row crazy
Honky Tonk Street Broadway right and it
was a Saturday night college football it
was mobbed there were like thousands and
thousands of college children out there
puking on each other and right hooking
up and doing whatever else they're doing
and you know five years ago I would have
said oh this is really disgusting I hate
everybody but now I was just like look
at the glory of life
and the next day I did what I always do
when I go to a new city I went to the
art museum and I I'd had a great time so
far in Nashville I'd barely been there a
day but it was wonderful it was open
mask free no one demanding to see my
vaccine papers right nothing like this
so I go to the art museum and the first
thing I see outside of the Frist is a
big sign that says I need a time to
ticket reserved online
I need a socially distance and I need to
wear a mask
and so I go in and it's empty there's
hardly anybody in there all of the art
was uh curatorially discussed only in
terms of its political value
yeah there was an art deco exhibit that
was all about you know the workers of
the WPA but it was a there was a ball
gown and they're telling me workers of
WPA and I'm like this is what do you do
they're sequence what are you talking
about and the massive disconnect between
these two cultural events was shocking
and I knew exactly which one I wanted to
be part of
um and I love art right like I'm a
snobby art person I knew exactly that I
would rather be puked on on Broadway
What She Said by drunk ass college
students then stuck in the Frist art
museum with no one making eye contact
because we're all like this and
terrified of each other reading
political diatribes from curators what
she's saying is she would prefer let's
go Brandon to Adele
that's true too yes and I've not even
heard either of them yeah exactly well
here's the thing I also I think that's a
very good point that we need Indie
culture I think it's good that the daily
wire is stepping out into this I think
any time an organization wants to make
content that promotes our values if they
do a decent job of it that's good I'm
here for it but there is something about
individual creators putting something
together in an independent fashion where
they don't have you know large investors
behind it again I'm not saying that's
necessarily a bad thing but it's also
really important and healthy to have
that Indie culture Vibe as well I love
that both yeah yeah that's what I always
that's the kind of art I always made
that's what I like I like weird art we
got to do it yeah the challenge is we'll
do it I've got some ideas quality
control is really difficult yeah um well
nothing I make is quality so throw that
out the window buddy marketing is very
difficult
um you know we can we can make good
shows but uh you know getting them out
there it's like we do have a big
audience but the audience size for like
a podcast versus translating translating
it something else is is very very
difficult yeah right so like the Vlog
gets like 25k views per day maybe like
30 000 total and it's a video format
most people who watch and listen are
here for like high level information
conversation podcast format so if we're
going to get into like a comedy special
will it translate probably not as well
but we have to just start building it up
and then hopefully over time you know
it'll take off so we're doing with sales
from the inverted world the first the
first uh series of articles that Shane
has made are kind of like ideas and
introductory and now he's got a bunch of
ghost stories from the Confederacy from
like Sherman's March to the Sea The Lost
gold the conspiracies so these are going
to be different books
like a legit full book of horror
Anthology ghost stories history you can
buy and read so we're going to be doing
everything
we I also talked to a company about
turning into a TV show yeah about weight
about turning what Taylor Swift that's
awesome taking taking these stories that
are that are non-fiction and using those
to make a fiction version cool I was
actually I was just on Shane's show the
other day uh he invited me we started
talking religion and then he's he asked
me he's like would you like to do the
show because I think we could have a
good conversation it was really cool it
was really cool great time talking to a
very smart guy very engaging it's
basically we have two shows the main
show Tales from the inverted world is
like Shane writes an essay in a story
and then talks about and explores his
ideas he went down to Georgia and
investigated the Lost Confederate goal
the conspiracies around that ghost
stories UFOs and then the members only
version is the is the discussion about
these ideas and the weird and the
Paranormal and things like that and so I
think we've got like three we're about
to put up
and then it's like it's like a different
it's it's similar ideas different show
but it's gonna be for members and it's
with Comics you know what you could do
the you could just ask people to send in
tapes
oh yeah tapes yeah just like ask you
know just put out an open call and you
know and that way you're not paying any
attention to ideology you're just paying
attention to good comedy and you could
say Hey you know if you're a comic out
there and you want to send us five
minutes or three minutes whatever it is
and then we'll see who gets to have a
special I think we can do a sitcom very
easily it's relatively cheap animated
shows get way more expensive animated
shows are expensive but you could just
do like a stand-up show and you could
feature Comics who are not breaking
through I mean the The Gatekeepers of
arts and entertainment culture are these
wokesters they're in these positions of
power in every single area from you know
comedy to drama to sitcoms or whatever
they're sitting there with the power and
you can bypass that by just going
directly to the artists who are out
there in the world and saying like what
do you got like send it on over
well we got to get to it we're going to
get to it but for now we'll get to Super
Chat so if you haven't already smash
that like super chat subscribe to the
channel go to timcast.com become a
member for all that awesome members only
content now I'll tell you this we've got
a couple episodes of The Green Room
which is a Friday show which is the
bonus content where we're downstairs
hanging out in the green room and the
last episode was Viva and Barnes hanging
out with everybody it's much less
topical it's just like us chilling and
then we have the cast Castle bonus Vlog
which is from the event we did on
Saturday so we're starting to produce
way more content for members I'm really
excited about Tales from the inverted
world because this is like the first
official non-timcast like non-tim pool
property we're expanding into where it's
Shane's hosting it a team is producing
this they're really great at what they
do there's art there's like a hundred
plus different images per episode and
it's either creepy amazing drawings and
we're gonna nft them you know we're
we're doing a bunch of ways to build
culture and create memories let me tell
you guys something real quick before we
do super chats
I was at this this seminar it's like a
lecture
the guy was talking about marketing and
how you effectively market and he says
there's a reason why you sell merch at a
show with like a band it's not to make
money it's so that the people who are
there who have a memory I came here with
my friends we saw this band play and
then you say here's their shirt they buy
it one day they go in their closet and
as they're moving their shirts they see
that and they remember that night you
are giving them a piece of that memory
they can never lose and they will always
remember exactly what it meant and where
it came from that's what you're actually
selling to people and so he talked about
the importance of selling literally
anything and everything you can
especially unique items right so like
the gorilla for instance or like Ian's
obsidian Stones we're going to be
selling this stuff periodically so that
people will have one-of-a-kind items to
remember you know what they watched why
they enjoyed things like that so this is
why we're going to be doing nfts that's
why we're going to be doing auctions all
of that stuff that being said let's read
some super chats can I address one of
these which was my name from Jr uh which
oh yeah so first of all thank you so
much for your Super Chat Jr what they
said was Sheamus you gotta lay off the
pagans we aren't inherently your enemies
so what I want to say here is I love you
as an individual person and my goal here
and I I like to joke and play around but
my goal here is not for somebody who
believes something differently than me
to walk away feeling like I dislike them
or don't care about them he's lying but
he's lying well except for Tim I don't I
don't care how Tim feels about anything
but I want you to know this I I care too
much about you to not question beliefs
you have that I think are wrong and I
believe that paganism is wrong
I tried having a a simple and open
conversation with with Sheamus about my
religion and the hollow Earth and the
lizard people that live inside of it but
he he was just insulting me no the
hollow Earth part was fine but when you
start coming at me talking about climate
change
no no no uh I watched that show inside
job Luke talked about it was pretty
funny second episode's way funnier than
the first it's
ah C plus B minus but it's funny so I
don't know this show it's a it's like
it's a show about conspiracy theories
the second episode a bunch of JFK clones
get released and so they have to get
grassy knoll his name is to hunt him
down and stop them
there's a bunch of JFK's walking around
they're like we need his help too soon
it's pretty yeah too soon all right
Christina H says rage on behalf of the
machine's Greatest Hits shelling in the
name yeah opposites of punk and chills
on Parade I'm gonna write those songs
those are great and we'll record them
I'm writing this down yeah write them
down I'll go to Carter who's our music
producer and be alike I need these
versions to be recorded like these songs
be recorded with these alternate lyrics
you better do what they tell you that's
right
all right let's see
Eric a says the let's go Brandon songs
have been gone from the iTunes app top
songs since at minimum yesterday I had
to search them out specifically posted
an image to patriots.win let's go
Brandon right here yeah but Libby
checked and she's got him maybe refresh
or something
weird they're just they're right here
hmm Jeremy Hall says Tim crew Have you
listened to the music of Tom McDonald
any chances of getting him on the show
we absolutely have and we I have talked
to him on the phone and you know about a
couple things maybe have you noticed how
busy he is right yes there's a lot of
very famous people we'd love to have on
the show you know
chance Jones says hey I told Loza
Alexander uh was legit let's go bite and
hit 3.7 million on YouTube and he was on
number one before Adele's song came out
also Bryson just hopping on the let's go
Brandon wave because it's trending loser
did it first Low's a gang I mean for
sure and Lowe's has got the bigger songs
like he's got more of them but Bryson
hit number one but you know mad respect
to everybody anybody who wants a chance
let's go Brandon I'm down with they're
my team HB says Trump is attending World
Series game four in Georgia it's gonna
rain let's go Brandon in the ATL
ah
all right
trash Banner says clearly we are winning
memes mockery and comedy are our weapons
yep satire sarcasm Chris p b bacon says
Casey cassim was also the voice of
Scooby-Doo that's right was it
Scooby-Doo someone said Shaggy yeah
[Music]
what's on there wasn't he
the thing though about satire and all of
that is it's getting fact checked I know
I know yeah exactly and the AFP which is
a global fact-checking organization came
out and said that it was right to fact
check satire because it's hard to tell
the difference these days well maybe
well that's more it's indicative of a
very serious cultural problem so I did a
video about this a while ago the fact
checking that was occurring via Snopes
in the Babylon bee and Snopes tried to
justify their fact checking by releasing
a study which showed that something like
in some cases up to 30 percent of
conservatives believed that this Babylon
B article was true what they actually
did was they took a number of Babylon B
articles removed them from the context
of having been produced by a satire
outlet and then they rewarded the
headlines
they rewarded the headlines to take the
jokes and they just stated them as if
they were factual so it was like one of
them is you know Joe Biden Don's
umbrella cap and then claims you know
free money for everyone and then they
take out the contacts and they put Joe
Biden offers plan to give Americans free
money or one was Is that real and people
are like oh it sounds real I guess I did
do that like well that wasn't especially
you believe in the satire well what
happened that did happen so
one concrete example was it was
um it was something like
oh man it was a parody of an argument
evangelicals will make
um about creation but it was it was
something like Don Lemon said that um
proof that collusion didn't happen was
like made to test our faith or so like
something was an obvious joke and they
reworded it to say Don Lemon has openly
stated that nothing could make him
change his mind about russiagate and
then ask people if that was a real
headline it's like that's completely
dishonest yeah
that's how they work all right Daniel
generelli says waking up to a text from
Tim's girlfriend Sunday morning equals
I'm living in a simulation seriously
though huge thanks to Allison and
everyone who signed my board can't wait
to mount it on my office wall I had so
much fun you're all cool and PS Ian I
hope you enjoyed the treats left with
Chris so this was uh the event we had oh
nice event on Saturday it was very very
fun
very fun and um we are planning another
um possibly another event soon of some
sort very soon
and this this too soon it's very hard to
organize we'll see though we'll see if
we can pull this off I don't want to say
too much Nashville oh excuse me oh you
just gotta okay what was that are you
sick you didn't tell me you were sick
Nashville yeah yeah what um
all right all right all right let's see
all right so this is Super Chat from
204-857-428-9572-9875 let's go Brandon
has medical misinformation because it
starts off with a part of speech by
button claiming that if you get the
vaccine you won't get covered oh my
goodness incredible well Biden is wrong
and he's sewing disinformation speaking
of Biden's sewing disinformation I
released a video yes I'm chilling for
myself once again called Biden debates
Biden's vaccine mandate we were able to
find audio clips of Biden like
diametrically opposed to himself on the
vaccine issue when Trump was in office
verse now so just watch that to
entertain yourself and also be informed
on Biden's news we didn't put Kamal
Harris in the video but I thought I saw
a number of her statements under the
Trump Administration it's really funny
it's really funny and then also you had
an April Biden saying that wearing a
mask was a patriotic Duty and now just
recently he was slammed for wandering
all around Virginia shaking everyone's
hands with his you know snot nose
kissing their hand wiping
sniffing people no masks no mask
all right frog boogers says Tim what in
1 000 Ways to Die IMDb cast in season 5
episode 4 death takes a vacation you are
labeled as pedestrian oh
yeah that's pretty rude that they would
call you pedestrian like that I don't
even know that's higher level but we
filmed too one where the mime kills
himself by eating a pickle and the other
one the cop does by dropping his gun and
picking it up wrong
no I know that's what I'm saying
all right Cole Will says it's a big
white pill for me to know that protest
music is making a comeback most Vietnam
protest era artists are either all dead
or they got the government they they
wanted except Clapton and Van Morrison
please read the chop block uh podcast
Super Chat right there
The Chop block podcast says I see Tim
pull as a guest again on shimcast and
I'll seriously love you guys and all you
do and hey lids and Libby oh hello hello
says Green Day's unreleased album you
mentioned was scrapped because the
master recordings were stolen slash lost
but when they restarted they made
American Idiot I don't believe it I
never believed it oh wow so they did
what the warning where it was like pop
rock and then people ragged on them
saying like you're not punk rock oh they
stole our stuff dog ate my homework
right oh no oh no oh our new album
they're probably looking at it it was
all like bubble gum and they're like
oops oh crap and so then they were like
we're punk rock we're gonna complain
about America they should have just
released it I mean the Ramones were
bubble gum Punk
that worked for them yeah you know
all right Steve high school or clip we
want bidenbops take my money oh yeah
well let me tell you we have we we have
bidenbops on freedom Tunes it's a
cartoon we did maybe I'll make a full
version but y'all gotta go check that
video out it's called Sing With Joe
Biden
so good all right dialogue equals
progress as on diversity equity and
inclusion I consult companies in many HR
departments are pursuing this because
they want to take advantage of cultural
differences and diversity of thought to
progress faster than the competition the
only problem is they all have homage
it's homogeneity of thought not
diversity
yeah Orion Galaxy says Crowder shot shot
his 1 million subscriber plaque full of
holes and hanged it you should do the
same if you'd ever strikes you down or
bans you
I do have an extra one
because we have three and then I got
sent a duplicate for some reason oh yeah
they accidentally sent me two can I put
my name on it so I can just pretend that
I have for millions of years but it's
funny that Luke never got his silver
medal yeah other people never got there
I never so I didn't get mine I didn't
get mine for a while and then I sent
them a photoshopped meme you know the
one of Timmy Turner's dad was like
here's where I'd put blank if I had I
did one but I photoshopped my cartoon
character's face and I was like I would
put my play button here if I had one and
I sent that to them and they responded
they're like we're so sorry yeah
true yes yes I put a little text than
the email but yeah I sent them that Meme
this is where I put my silver metal I
had one
all right let's see
Jack T great says when I show you this
picture do you see a yellow dress or
let's go Brandon got him
let's see blind owl says a slow slow
clap to Luke and freedom tunes for that
Biden's Greatest Hits short it made me
genuinely laugh thank you so much why
why Luke well because Luke's only did
all the work you know yeah Luke did the
freedom Tunes video I love Luke but he
was not involved with that yeah I was
confused by that I'm like look at
nothing yeah thank you I'm so glad you
liked that cartoon it was Sheamus though
yeah
all right let's see
what do we get oh maybe he was saying
shout out to Luke comma and Sheamus for
this okay that makes sense Luke's gonna
be so mad mad when he finds out I saw
his cartoon
Freedom tune for that Biden Greatest
Hits and huh
all right let's see Audrey visual
Audrey's Visual Arts says Sheamus as a
villain would be a formidable opponent
as brilliant as he is on Kyle's defense
can you imagine if the MSM had someone
on the staff that's smart thankfully
he's on our side that's very kind of you
thank you yeah I think they have plenty
of people on their side as smart as me
they're all pretty dumb yeah
they're all pretty dumb all right
Ray says fascism started in Earnest with
the Patriot Act sounds about right that
was pretty bad yeah Kev says Casey
Castle voiced Shaggy in the Scooby-Doo
cartoons from 1969 to 2012. wow old guy
175 yeah Greg dubier says Sheamus why do
you only promote Freedom Tunes when you
also have common sense soapbox because
the super Chatters will promote it for
me clearly
so common sense soapbox is a channel
that I've been running it's a series I
started producing with the foundation
for economic education about five years
ago and we launched a channel for it
about a year ago so yeah feel free to
check out Common Sense soapbox with
Seamus Coggin Freedom Tunes is my main
channel so I I do most of the promoting
for that one and Common Sense soapbox is
a joint venture uh currently so
right on very cool but yeah check it out
we just did a bit we just did a very
informative video uh on the budget and
how it is a myth to say that we could
cut the defense budget to pay for all
the social welfare spending people want
we actually don't have enough yeah so
check that video out on comments and
soapbox if you'd like Jonah Dave davidov
says call Chief diversity officers what
they are commissars and there you go
Yeller bee says Hey Temple and gang
what's your opinion on these meme coins
and the reason people are flooding into
it do you think it says something about
society's opinion faith on the US dollar
I just found a coin I wonder if other
people will buy some as an fu yeah
people are spamming uh certain coins I
don't shout them out because if there's
no real functional utility
or like
ethereum does as a function
some other tokens have functions Bitcoin
is a function bitcoin's mostly first and
best rest
a lot of these other tokens that are
built off of ethereum don't do anything
and people are just trying to justify
why they want everyone to buy it so they
can make a quick buck and then sell it
that's the way it is
pump and dump
Sergeant Wilkie says companies are
charging employees because they're
unvaccinated my employer is charging a
hundred dollars a month and I read an
article La workers charged 130 a week
just returned from Hawaii and all
restaurants required vax ID location of
stay or a negative test every 48 Hours
gee I I wonder what the party of workers
rights is gonna have to say about that
hmm very little yes
they like this kind of segregation Yep
they're then they're totally on board
with it even though in New York anyway
the majority of people who are
unvaccinated are black New Yorkers yeah
right yeah but that's not racist
everything no not at all systemically
racist except vaccine enforcement
anytime exactly anytime you have a
disproportionate outcome between two
groups of people it's it's racism except
except for this right except for vaccine
enforcement yeah Gail reinoff says love
you Tim and crew can you paint the
screws on your book display shelf black
they are very distracting and takes away
from The Classy shelf I am 64 and watch
you every night thank you very much Gail
that's the shelf behind you yeah oh
she's right oh the screws are very
obvious and distracting I hate this too
yeah what painted black no I think it
looks good you see your red door and you
want to paint a black lady
well now it's for when guests have
something to promote like a book oh
that's handy yeah that's why it's there
it was uh was it John R's idea yes a
super chatter that's right brilliant
that's a great idea brilliant it was a
great I should have put something back
there yeah why didn't you tell the guest
about it I know usually we put the
alpacas they didn't tell me about it
either yeah
that's very decorative and I like it so
we stopped doing plastic water bottles
yeah good for you yeah we decided to do
to buy some glass ones we can clean and
then we fill it with our own 18 stage
filter water gotta watch that tonight 18
stages yeah it's very clean good for you
fukit Freddy says Sheamus Day of the
Dead falls on All Saints Day in the
correct Catholic calendar so it's a way
to remember family as well yeah no
absolutely so uh All Saints Day is a day
when we remember and pray for the dead
and celebrate the Saints and uh yeah I
believe Day of the Dead also falls on
that date November 1st oh very
interesting yeah All Hallows Eve is
Halloween all Halloween yes I have
somebody trying to tell me on Twitter
that Halloween had nothing to do with
Christianity or religion that is absurd
and I was like yeah it's the eve before
a holy day of obligation yeah exactly
yeah kind of the point no obviously like
not all the customs of Halloween or Day
of the Dead for that matter are
necessarily Christian or even something
that Christians should partake in
frankly but in its origin yeah it's
Christian all right here's a good one
Jay leib God says the crazy thing about
the Kentucky lap dance story is that it
was in Hazard County I can't see Beau
and Luke uh Duke doing this Daisy maybe
goodness gracious times they are a
changing
yeah
all right let's see Jeffrey grayjick
says I got a kick out of hearing here
was this drink called tang and didn't
astronauts drink that I guess also by
the way I saw a tweet that said and this
makes so much more sense it was
orangutans in the tank that were
chilling outside
now I get it maybe that was maybe I was
looking for chimpanzees and there was a
character I've been looking for
orangutans you might have seen something
that was your problem that was the issue
Matthew Drake said Alec Baldwin crossed
state lines and shot a woman oh
technically correct yeah well and you
you know you can use framing to like
really mess with people's minds on
stories so Alec Baldwin traveled really
really far out of state crossing state
lines specifically for the purpose to go
where this woman was working and then
point a gun at her and pull the trigger
and now she's dead all technically
correct literally correct
the only thing is they don't tell you
it's like he was on a movie and you know
that's how the media works it's the
information they withhold more so than
the information they give you afraid to
not check your props like that's what I
find so
but think about how they framed it at
first a prop gun
but it wasn't a prep gun and it didn't
misfire right it was a real gun that was
a real ball used as a prop fired
intentionally fired yep that's yeah
that's crazy that was really the only
way to to fire yeah you have to pull the
actual trigger not a prop all right
Dragon Lady says amen I was one of those
kids so offensive right because
Hispanics are especially Mexicans are
very often Catholic not all the time but
to co-opt their culture which is
generally Catholic to promote sexual
lifestyle choices that we believe are
immoral it's extremely insulting death
style choices she goes on to say Latinos
wake up because we are being colonized
again I just got that it's true yeah
lawyer Laura Laura says first thing my
parents taught me when I was old enough
to be home alone don't open the door for
anyone that's right yeah especially
witches unless it's a witch unless it's
a witch she's getting it anyway right
she'll teleport it I guess
J.R says Tim T-Bones are hard to cook
because they're actually like three
separate steaks well we're gonna slow
cook them for like 12 hours so it just
turns to Mush gee you look great
brisket is the best period
that's it you like brisket the best time
it's the best good brisket old brisket
Tim they call them falls apart yeah I
don't know I gotta be on a tenderloin
man wow mignon crazy it is delicious so
insanely good
harder and harder to come by I went to
this one farm and the lady told me that
someone showed up and bought my fancy
meat that's right
fanciest
it's like 15 for a steak that's kind of
a lot but it's like kind of a lot yeah
but you know how much a porterhouse
costs
it's just it's a little bit bigger I
mostly just buy vegetables and pasta
like well look look I'll put this way
when you go to a farm to buy meat and
you're getting fresh farm meat
everything is between 15 20 bucks and
the tender loins are 15 bucks I used to
live near a place that slaughtered
chickens on the Lower East Side and
after living near that place for just a
brief period of time I didn't want to
eat chicken really ever ever again I
would never have gone I wanted more some
fresh chicken their screaming would
annoy me and I'd hate them even more I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding I'm
kidding
smell with gasoline I briefly lived
across the street from a chicken
slaughtery and at like tomorrow morning
you'd hear like oh that's horrible yeah
all right then no I mean the noise you
made was funny but it's horrible for
actually it's just you're the Mass
Slaughter of any animals not a
comfortable would you uh would you eat
lab grown organic meat product yeah yeah
um that didn't come from animals it was
just like yeah yeah we yeah we bought um
we bought this fungus ice cream they
make they make lactose they genetically
modified a mushroom so that it grows
lactose I guess and they take it out and
they make
a non-animal dairy with it add a little
bit because I'm not I'm trying to avoid
all the sugary garbage but uh I have no
problem eating that stuff I would just
choose not to if I had the choice if you
had the choice yeah so my choice is I
have chickens we have 15 chickens now
it's the craziest thing right check this
out you get a chicken and you get a
rooster and you just put them outside
you're gonna do it you end up with more
chickens yeah yeah that's true the other
day I saw Tim and he had one of the
chickens and he was just like beating it
mercilessly and then like they it
finally died actually and I was like now
we can eat it and Tim's like eat it we
dropped it there what's wrong with you
no we actually have it we actually have
a very serious chicken City problem
right now
so Dorothy who was a re-home and she's
the oldest she's being seriously abused
by Roberto oh no like oh yeah dude
chickens are not night dude roosters are
not nice animals well so she runs from
him now panicked frantic and then he
chases her and then jumps on her and
doesn't he just jumps on her and then
stands there wow and so like we're like
okay we need to get this new thing set
up we're separating them all so that
she'll have time to like be by herself
and heal and then he'll have to find
other preferences I guess but yeah so
let's gonna move on to the next victim I
mean recidivism is very high for those
kinds of roosters I want to do like an
animation we have a um our Canadian
editor at post Millennials Roberto wake
girl Cruz and I want to do an animation
of him with a
chicken body doing this with Dorothy
here's the thing though so so we have
Judy Garland there's some chicken two
batches of babies we've got the uh
there's three babies it's a Margaret's
two daughters and then Roberto's son and
then we have five babies that are black
stars those are Vanessa and Dorothy's
kids they're they're a special Sex Link
from Rhode Island red and and Bart
Plymouth Rock and they all they all do
their separate thing and so one day
Roberto Jr his son was grabbing the neck
of one of Margaret's daughters really
hard and he ran in and split them up and
I was like oh he's being a good dad
right and I'm actually impressed I go
out there and I was worried that you
know the rooster would kill the other
boys and everything he he actually keeps
him safe yeah about that that is good
yeah but I was told that they don't care
for their kids and they were incubated
babies so he really doesn't care for
them he just views them as other
chickens but he's actually doing a good
job over for everybody now the the
little boys are still babies so they're
not yet sexually mature so we don't have
to worry about any fighting or anything
like that but we we're gonna separate
them apparently makes sense yeah I've
thought about getting chickens my
landlord doesn't allow pets but I think
livestock is different you know if I got
some of those yeah yeah
you know what I was thinking I was
thinking of just buying like 50 roosters
and just unleashing them in a city
let's not do that just open the back of
a truck at 4am what would happen no we
should try that and just like see if it
becomes a news story just don't tell
anyone just let it happen and see people
like there's chickens running around our
neighborhood what what and how big of a
store it becomes not chickens roosters
because they'll be screaming
they're fighting each other and running
away oh my gosh we just introduced
chickens and roosters as an invasive
species
about farming there's no natural
predators in cities for chickens who's
gonna go out there there's there's
possums raccoons nope can't get them
chicken's too big chicken possums can't
get chickens I'm pretty sure chickens
and roosters are too big for possums
possums are like just coyotes foxes
raccoons so or raccoons maybe if they
get into the city
but you know I think if you just
Unleashed a horde of chickens into like
Central Park you'd have chickens
everywhere you would have chickens
everywhere it's interesting in Brooklyn
Park let's do it dude I think you should
do this I won't tell anybody okay dude
if this happens that that's gonna happen
right and someone's actually gonna
release chickens and then the media is
going to go ins chicken Insurrection
promoted by Tim Poole people are saying
cats that is not true not for tickets
what about cows cats cannot we'll get
messed up by a chicken yeah dude dude
chick people you need to understand
chickens are armored those feathers yeah
it's like armor and then they have claws
well they're basically like dinosaurs
yeah and so yeah
are tough but they're soft they're very
soft do you want to know how we ended up
with a bunch of possums in Brooklyn they
released a bunch of possums in Brooklyn
to try and control the rat population no
way when was it it was a while ago but
now we have rats and Simpsons amazing
and squirrels and they're all super
nasty well we have we've got stink bugs
everywhere and they're an invasive
species and so one thing people were
saying is that the reason they're
spreading is because in China where
they're from there's wasps that kill and
eat them simple which you need to bring
the Wasps over here that's a good idea
let's do that brilliant let's do that
they'll kill all those things like
spectacular no have you seen that why
didn't we all think of that and do it
already have you seen that weird spotted
bug that's invasive those those
lightning that kill the trees yeah yeah
horrible I went to
um we were in Harrisburg PA and we went
to a restaurant and there was like a
thousand just like clustered all over
this building and I was like I'm pretty
sure you got to call the cops or
something like
you're like obligated and they called or
something like that but I was just like
dude and they're flying everywhere
really disgusting yeah yeah that's
horrible yeah nasty why why haven't you
guys smash that like button for sure
yeah guys hold on why haven't you
smashed the like button for this episode
of timcast that's ridiculous that's
right so how many likes are we at Lids
bro we're at 8 330. oh no that's enough
actually no that's enough oh okay no
let's get us to 15 000. it's ambitious
but we're going for it today let's do it
Jake Berg says Tim pool is a CIA plant
and these videos aren't even live I can
prove it's live right now how do you
read that Super Chat videos aren't real
well you just proved it by reading the
Super Chat he knows I'm gonna prove it
right now writing the time and date
writing my fancy pen there you go very
cool it's like 1862 isn't it I'm
concerned but Tim you knew when the
podcast was going to start airing so you
knew that yeah this is live right now
see
can you read that 8 17 p.m 10 26 21. oh
that's right that's right I wouldn't
have driven straight into the sun all
afternoon either for something that
wasn't even live y'all I know what were
you thinking Libby I don't know so now
here's here's what I'm really excited
for just fake that was that super chat
came in a few minutes ago at 9 50 um
it's fine 9 59 pm and but now people are
going to be like whoa Tim held up the
wrong time and date like I bet the shows
aren't even actually live even though
the news is from today no would it be
like it would be such a bad idea to
record this early we should do an
episode 17. that's funny it's funny it's
a good bet yeah age 17. yesterday we
should do one episode I just noticed
that we should actually record an
episode ahead of time just one day when
we on when we wanted to hang out later
in the day or something and then the
whole time we'll just be like trying to
talk about the day's events we know
nothing about like this did you hear
about that thing that one day Joe Biden
Joe can you believe what he said oh that
thing Simpsons episode when they replace
all of the radio talk show hosts with a
computer and then the computer is just
like those clowns in Congress and
Homer's like oh yeah
well we didn't quite hit Sheamus's goal
of 15 000 likes no that's pretty messed
up so that means that means no after
show sorry no that means we're kicking
Sheamus out oh that people don't realize
you know Sheamus you got it yeah I was
gonna have a well a scotch in the after
show so let's def do that no it's fine
we'll do that but Sheamus Sheamus where
he's leaving okay Sheamus is gone he's
gone oh
what are you saying over there Sheamus
so you guys can't hear it no no we'll
never know all right everybody if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel go over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have an after Show members only coming
up at 11 PM
you don't want to miss it you can um
what'd I say subscribe to this channel
share the show uh follow us at
timcast.com you can follow me personally
at timcast you guys want to shout out to
your things yeah so if you want to help
us out we're at thepostmillennial.com
contribute and you can check that out
and we're there every day thepost
millennial.com I'm at Libby Emmons on
Twitter and next weekend if you're in
Fort Worth I'm going to be at better
discourse which is better
discourse.com and you guys could uh
check that it's live I mean that's a
real place that's a real thing happening
I don't know if it's streaming but I'm
going to be there with a bunch of other
people Jack beshop is going to be there
oh nice that should be really cool yeah
so jackpot sobik I hit him up before the
event that we had this past weekend and
I asked him if he was going to come he's
gonna you know I don't know if we'll be
able to and I said so you're saying you
don't love us and he responded Yes oh
wow yeah and I have the tweets I can
prove it so I'm just telling everyone
here that's literally what happened but
if you want to follow me check out my
work youtube.com freedomtunes that's
oons Freedom tunes and that's pretty
much where you get to see all my fun
funky crazy cartoons they're very
enjoyable I think you guys will love
them
give us a series of Joe Biden Tunes Joe
Biden's song is getting confused it's
t-o-o-n-s his channel yeah nice it's
awesome it's so good um I really enjoy
this kind of mixed up version of Tim
cast IRL I was loving this new I guess
this is shimcast yeah Luke and Ian are
eating stink bugs right now that's
actually why Tim brought them out here
supposedly they taste like apples don't
recommend trying them you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch
l-y-d-s the internet yeah the internet
told me I'm surprised they don't taste
like chicken I know right everything
does right oh it tastes like chicken
all right thing does I guess that's it
there you go Tim all right everybody
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
for that member segment thanks for
hanging out thanks for